[Music]
brand-new podcast with today's guest al
Madrigal who has a Showtime special
airing this Friday night Cinco de Mayo
at Nueve o'clock called shrimp and ain't
easy make sure to put it in your DVRs
you go to the Showtime app as you know
if you're a fan of this podcast you
watch mine there you can get a week free
trial all you got to do is put an email
make it a password and bam you get the
free Showtime app I'm gonna probably
send out that email but al Madrigal real
quick will do the intro up front number
two tour dates so that you can hear the
intro and then if you want to skip my
tour dates like a [ __ ] [ __ ] like a
[ __ ] selfish prick [ __ ] then you
can do that then you can just you know
click that four button like a [ __ ]
dick like a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] dick
then just hit that skip four button or
you can listen to the whole thing I'll
try to make it entertaining al Madrigal
is a comic that when I first heard of
him was the dude by the way this V dude
has been working consistently in this
business since that day he's been on I
think nine sitcoms he was on The Daily
Show most recently he is the founder of
all things comedy the thing I'll say
about Al is the first time I heard about
him they were like dude you gotta watch
this guy work he's [ __ ] phenomenal he
was a Comedy Store guy he got seen by
Dave Chappelle Dave Chappelle brought
him on the road
he got seen by Mitch Hedberg Mitch
Hedberg brought him on the road he is
[ __ ] one of the coolest guys he's the
kind of guy that I remember like hanging
out with him he was the kind of guy that
could like if you had a joint and you
passed around he'd take a hit off the
joint and if you want to have a drink
he'd always have a drink with you he was
cool as [ __ ] and he never got faded
although he says he did the podcast he
says he does but like every time I was
with him I was like man I wish I was
more like that he's like taking a couple
hits off the joint just hang out and his
writing is phenomenal it really is one
of the few comics that I watched him was
like [ __ ] man
I don't write at all like I'm just I'm
not that good at all we did a we talked
about this on the podcast you're gonna
really love this podcast but uh but yeah
al is different than all of us comics I
will say that
because he is as talented as all of us
but at the same time he is a guy who has
a business acumen that is above and
beyond that's the reason he started all
things comedy with bill burr trust me I
love you bill but we all know that if
one for Alan under that [ __ ] would have
gotten done
that's [ __ ] out for you he's I gather
he's a hard worker he's got like nine
projects going on in any given time
actually he says in this a great deal
more than nine and and he's a father of
two he's a great dad he's dialed in he
coaches soccer he's just a [ __ ] guy
that is a comic you look up to I get a
lot of guys who come back - the man came
in they always go wow you're like a real
dad not part of me goes I guess you've
never been to Alice for Christmas Eve
because you go to Alan's of Christmas
Eve and he's like Clark Griswold but
Mexican so so and his family's the
future his wife's Korean he's Mexican
and that is what the world will look
like one day his children we talk about
all this about being a dad about doing
the road about partying about [ __ ]
everything this is a great podcast so I
hope you enjoy it I'll say his name one
more time but right now is when I'm in
to do tour dates so don't skip ahead
just listen because if you live in
Detroit then you already know that those
shows that the corporate lounge are sold
out this Thursday May 4th but it if you
live in Cincinnati
or better yet Liberty Township then you
know that I have shows on the 5th and
6th of May in your city I'll be doing
kid Chris in the morning I hope I really
hope because I just announced it so not
super happy about that that ship checked
kid Chris will you please have me on
your show thank you um I got the
crapshoot Comedy Festival is happening
in Vegas on the 19th and it pigs they're
Notaro their bronzers they're sticklers
they're the [ __ ] list is insane of
what all the comics at the crapshoot
comedy fest I'm doing a pot live podcast
in the afternoon and then I show that
evening and then the next morning I'm
getting on a plane and flying to Bisbee
Arizona where we are doing a show that
evening on live podcast me and Stanhope
on the 20th I will be drunk it will be
chaos it is sold out and then I'm going
to thinking about sticking around busy
for like a day or two just [ __ ] chill
it's nice it kind of resets your your
artistic clock to be around really
original people and those people that
that compound
is is inspiring artistically to say the
least
so yeah the Blue Note in Hawaii may 31st
I'll be at the store a bunch in May so
always to go to the comedy store in May
and stop by I do a lot of Tuesday night
shows there because it's easier for my
family I'll probably doing maybe I'd
like to do a weekend at the store I've
never done a weekend at the store though
bill burr and I are doing a show on the
10th of May at the Comedy Store so yes
the 10th of May bill burr and I our
headline in the main room so
co-headlining but I will probably be
going first so go to them there the man
tonight you're going to late I already
did that show and that's the blue nut
and then I got cobs comedy club the
ninth and 10th of June Sacramento
punchline the 11th of June
Kansas City Orlando Cherokee Casino at
the very end of the month Columbus
Pittsburgh Cleveland hilarities in July
and big announcement Australia I'm
coming in September we're doing a tour
in Australia I say we it's just me but I
will be in Australia we're doing a
couple theaters or maybe three theaters
three a gala I don't know what I'm doing
but I just got the offer I'm announcing
it the tickets aren't in sale maybe I
should have waited but let's jump the
gun boy do I have another bigger
announcement I think everyone's going to
be jacking off over I think Trust
actually I have two big announcements
that I know you guys are going to lose
your [ __ ] minds over and it's not me
it's not a big happening with my career
but it's something I'm involved in that
when you hear it you're going to go shut
the [ __ ] up I'm getting tickets for that
so actually for things if you really
think about it for things you know what
five things if you think about it five
things come to think of it six things
six things still working on my scripted
show we're breaking the story now I have
sold a couple things that we should be
shooting soon and I will announce those
and that's that really I think I wish I
could keep up anymore there's a long
enough intro for know some of that
didn't have anything to promote let's
pray to God I [ __ ] did this right
anyway today's podcast guest like I said
has an hour special airing this Friday
on Showtime
DeMeo at Nueve o'clock so make sure to
tune in he is my good friend he is a
hilarious comic he is a working actor
host [ __ ] podcaster entrepreneur dad
[ __ ] all-around badass dude who can
handle his alcohol ladies and gentlemen
put your hands together for my friend al
Madrigal
[Music]
so wait what usually mean you're waking
up my breath full yeah yeah yeah
fully out of breath Jenny we wake up in
the middle of the night really yeah why
are you wearing a Utah Jazz Southern
Utah last week I'm a [ __ ] big head he
was humble sweet so you just went to the
doctor just left the doctor's office I
had set up with three different
referrals the first one she set me up
with was for a cognitive behavioral
therapist oh she didn't cause panic
attacks I'm having I've always had a
problem so if you listen to the ATC live
podcast and me and Bill burr rarely do
yeah he thinks I'm a crazy person so he
and that's crazy person I think you know
so funny you are someone that people
talk about because you're an interesting
[ __ ] person you are very different
than the average comic I have a business
background that they like to think of me
as like a normal dad they're a normal
guy I certainly bounce into that way
more I'm finding myself starting to like
hanging out with the normal dads that I
hang out with just as much as I do the
comics and I could see myself
transitioning away from the comics and
comedy clubs I'm going through a whole
[ __ ] crisis right now that I could
talk to you about really what it's a
problem like I feel I wake up in the
middle of the night and I'm up in the
middle of the night for two hours okay
starting about 2:00 a.m. 3:00 a.m. I'll
wake up and I'll wake up going like [ __ ]
you're freaking out and I thought it was
my heart yeah and if you read well you
get physicals Ritchie this is what I
just left one nobody I mean do you get
for once a year once a year okay yeah
okay so blood work she goes nothing's
going on with your blood pressure you're
really cool by the way I highly
recommend this for every single guy in
my age hot doctor oh I would tiny ugly
Jewish one really woman or a man or a
woman no that's all right
so I leave my hot doctor
and she she's great but she basically
says you're everything looks good but
we're going to send you in for all your
blood work you get a PSA test my dad
died of cancer in June June 5th of last
year and he had cancer all over his
entire body he was given five months to
live seven years ago really so he just
was a trooper and stuck it out was in
horrible pain my dad's best friend was a
pain management guy so my dad's best
buddy was a physician that was a pain
blocker
so he's like trust me you'll never
suffer you're good my dad had oxycontin
lollipops you know that [ __ ] that
Michael Jackson died of my dad had like
Listerine tabs of yeah I guess so
he was good but he was in a tremendous
amount of pain so I have a history of
heart disease cancer I feel like I'm
gonna [ __ ] die because I flip out and
that's what bill makes fun of me for is
I sorta flip out I do I die if I see
[ __ ] like I'm not happy go-lucky
like IM b you so much because you're
such a jolly [ __ ] guy I'm a [ __ ]
mess I'm a mess I have a thing I just
talked to soda about this as I had by
the way the greatest weekend with Dan
Soder we were doing different clubs in
the same city
oh that's I did that with him in
Vancouver I was shooting a TV show and
he was in Vancouver and I hung out with
him all [ __ ] weekend yeah and we
talked we it was so nice we talked just
[ __ ] gossip for [ __ ] literally six
hours so people don't realize that when
you're a comedian you travel to another
city and then you look up who's at the
other Club I've had this happen with
Nick Thune spent all freakin with ya and
with Dan Soder you had even on the
podcast last week Nick soon I got a kick
out of Nick is one of my might be my
most memorable podcast I'll ever have
because we walk in and he just pulls
that kettle one bottle off there and he
goes I'm gonna need a pole to just
straighten out a little bit this morning
and just takes a pull off of it like all
right all right let's have a drink Nick
dude this is a goes perfectly in line
with what we were talking about in terms
of me flipping out being Nick Thune or
in Atlanta at a bar and we're standing
there minding our
own [ __ ] business and some guy walks
up out of nowhere drunk guy yeah
and takes Nixon's shirt and tussles it a
little bit like he just grabs the collar
he flips it around and I look at the guy
and then I look at Nick and like what
the [ __ ] was that you know in another
man yeah why is he touch where's this
guy touching you and Nick goes you know
I just had I just had a baby I'm not
gonna you know he's a drunk guy you're
letting it go I'm not going to get in a
fight in an Atlanta bar and like that
was weird
there's I somebody comes up and touches
me I don't know if I'm that cool so then
we're hanging out outside smoking
cigarettes drinking you know comics on
the road all of us we were drinking
heavily yeah outs outside bar girls came
from the show like Johnny Sanchez was
featuring for me so [ __ ] Johnny's
there was like just a really good time
yeah and then the same guy comes again
and he walks up and he gets Nick's Harry
puts his hand in Nick's hair and starts
rubbing around in his hair and I look at
the guy and I go I grab my beer mug like
one of those things where you're gonna
[ __ ] punch somebody in the face with
the beer mug and I pick it up I go you
better get the [ __ ] out of here or else
is gonna be a problem and then his
friends come rushing over and he was
from Google problems like that I go yeah
there's a [ __ ] problem here your
buddy needs to [ __ ] sit the [ __ ] down
or he's going to get this [ __ ] glass
in his face
like that and we're like oh and I don't
know why there but I go to [ __ ] like
I picked up a dude I was in [ __ ] yeah I
was having a slice of pizza after shows
in San Francisco controlled anyway the
story and [ __ ] this guy was [ __ ]
they were drunk and he was nudging me
and his girlfriend saw me pick up my
[ __ ] of a fork yeah like I was just
gonna [ __ ] prison-style a [ __ ]
just jab on box
and I really felt like I was going to my
wife this is all it was I'm going to see
a therapist about all this [ __ ]
and I woke up in the middle of my
breathing heavy because I imagine myself
in fights I was walking through the
Glendale Galleria with my wife and this
guy like this is our Armenian Punk was
walking towards us and I had a daydream
about him hitting my kids and doing
something to my wife and I grabbed my
wife's hand and then i clenched my other
fist and she goes oh my god you just
thought about killing that guy didn't
you and I go yeah I did I'm so sorry
like I'm just like another way out of
this I mean is it is it conditioning I
don't know what happened to me I don't
know if any of this is real I'd really
again I've never been in joke to couple
people in college like I saw this guy
was like [ __ ] her ass like really
like date rapey situation where this guy
was really [ __ ] [ __ ] with this
chick and he was much bigger than I am
and I went straight for his [ __ ]
throat and I started choking him until
people pulled me off I was on the road
with Doug Benson
and we word in Detroit doing a High
Times comedy tour yeah where this is how
long ago TJ Miller was a new Chicago
comic talking about how he was going to
move to LA Wow yeah so me and Doug are
on the road high times comedy tour and
we're in a pool hall slash rock club
that it was just one of the worst shows
I've ever done
Doug Benson to two minutes and walked
offstage I hit my full 25 and I'm
closing and I go if you guys could just
shut the [ __ ] up I go I'm just gonna
finish you down front if you could just
be quiet I'm just gonna do my closer and
get the [ __ ] out of here there's a
horrible kick hi Jeff say I go let me
just do my last five and he goes don't
mind me just do your jokes just do your
jokes and gives me that hand thing of
like just get out of my face and I
looked at him I go alright [ __ ]
I go I'm gonna finish my act and then
I'm going to come down there and beat
[ __ ] out of you I was just so irritated
with every area of this man
every Sharon does piano it wasn't our
fault it was kid material that's funny
it's like a thing
is it [ __ ] it was just like this bit
about um yeah my kids have big [ __ ] and
closer
put the mic in the mic stand marks down
there grab the guy by the back he didn't
you know he was shocked I grabbed the
guy by the shirt that's another thing
that people don't realize I play these
meet characters and I will but I'm
[ __ ] a hundred ninety pounds like I
go to the gym in almost constantly like
I [ __ ] grabbed a dude night dragged
his ass into the pool hall and I [ __ ]
I said I warned you [ __ ] and I
got [ __ ] just scarred that's coconut
better than the bouncer and everybody
playing pool like barely flames like
it's Detroit cool aw you know I know
what are you like uh there's somebody
else getting choked over there raising
eyebrows exactly and then on the bouncer
came running up the promoter came
running up laughing I hear Doug say if
anybody else [ __ ] makes another sound
I'm walking away somebody goes like [ __ ]
oh this walks out Shelly's got it Doug's
got a trigger temper like he has no
patience for that [ __ ] but he shouldn't
because and now he's in a spot and
you're in a spot Segura's in a spot and
everybody what comics want to get to is
they want to get to a place where
they're people come to see them yeah and
you and I have been at this a long time
and we say we blend through that's the
trials of a comic it's like no one knows
who you are and then you have some
credits enough to get booked as a
headliner at these comedy clubs and
still people don't really know who you
are they just see a bunch of things and
then they come and some people know so
maybe 30% of the people know who you are
yeah and the rest are there just to see
comedy or maybe they even paper the room
and it's a [ __ ] disaster like I've
had instances if they were [ __ ]
camera I'm sure there's gotta be phone
video of me losing my [ __ ] I have a cup
of those before cellphones of me falling
apart I have the exact opposite problem
that you have I see Dan and I were
talking about this this weekend I'm such
a nice guy that I feel like I get taken
advantage of a lot by the club owner and
by an audience by anybody like I
actually my whole thing has always been
do show do the meet and greet and then
drink with the audience like stay at the
club and drink or go meet everyone in a
bar and I think that I think I'm done
doing it for the rest of my life looks
like I just officially stopped I was in
Buffalo and some lady I go out I rarely
go out I go out to the bar I think I was
selling something at the time so I had a
bunch of CDs I sold them and then people
are hanging out I have such a weird
group of people right before we started
this podcast I was talking about to you
I go I have a special coming out on
Friday yeah might be it pretty good
solid chance that this my done I'm
walking away let me tell you why - so
I'm at this [ __ ] Buffalo Club yeah
and this while ago but I'm standing
there and the bartender knew what I was
drinking and a lady walks up and I drink
a variety of things how pretty much
drink anything I'm not a big scotch fan
but I see all the burl of bourbon yeah
you know I own part of a distillery yeah
you got did that with the daily show
guys right yeah I guys are gonna get you
I think you got me about a bottle I'll
bring I'll get more sent oh yeah please
Van Brunt still house it's great stuff
so I'm there I'm drinking a vo press
which is a Seagram's vo yeah ginger ale
and splashes soda with a little bit it's
a drink of lemon twist you could drink
19 of those things it's the best drink
ever
it's an old man trick I was at a wedding
when I was 21 years old this guy Nick
sappin are as old guy Oh grandfather
guys my best friend's grandfather came
up to the barn ago 35 veal presses and I
go what is that make it six your order
five of a drink I'll just one and he
goes
the only drink you ever need to drink
the rest of your life so I got one I
made
I think that's [ __ ] delicious it's
like drinking um uh uh it's refreshing
like this [ __ ] it what's a call to
impress it's a Presbyterian you can make
a press out of anything so you take any
sort of hard liquor distill you take a
bourbon you can make one with bourbon
and you take a little bit of ginger ale
in a bourbon press or presbyterian put
it I think a little bit of bitters as
well yeah and it's with a lemon and with
a little dash of club soda and it's
[ __ ] refreshing so if you go to like
Musso and Frank's or an old school place
yeah and say I need a Presbyterian the
bartender or the [ __ ] guy will look
at you just like those guys are you
doing this is an oil yeah and you know
very subtly do I get inspired to drink
you already got it isn't saying oh I was
like I'm not gonna drink tonight now I'm
definitely getting a vo vo press man
ginger ale can a Canada Dry dragon side
notch whoops and then dash of club soda
and a little bit of lemon I can just the
best warm weather drink or if you really
know you're going to drink a lot of
something you want to go with that
because we started I grew up in San
Francisco in North Beach I told a what
happened with the little lady told her
I'm going to leave out of [ __ ] I'll go
off on tangents left or right I'm said
at the bar
the glady can brings a vo press over and
she goes here I got this drink for you
about you a drink
I go lady you didn't have to buy me a
drink I drink for free yeah that's no
big deal and she started going on and on
how she had a horrible week and she
started talking to me because she felt
like she I owed her the time because she
bought me the drink and she even said as
much I go when I was talking to you man
I'm gonna go settle up here and talk to
her this Friday
yeah I got to go settle up with the club
real quick because I walked you that
drink and you were going to talk to me
because I deserved that too huh
chucking nutsack so I took $20 out of my
pocket and I go here you go now you
didn't buy me a drink
I gotta walk away see that's it it was
good meeting you I end up sitting there
and taking an ear beating all [ __ ]
night there were these two guys very
nice in Calgary very nice I think one
might I'm not really certain but the one
of the guys would just wouldn't he
literally he almost got in the car when
I was I walked out of the bar and then
got in a car and he almost walked in the
car he almost got in the car he and I he
I was like hey man I gotta go but like I
feel like I feel like you're very
accessible you put you of this
podcasting you have you know you were
talking about the special and we you had
yours on Showtime and I have mine come
and punch your town we were talking
about [ __ ] you should do and you go dude
you can put out a video every day yeah I
would never do that I know it was like
[ __ ] I am the worst like I just
announced the 49ers draft pick which
disorder told you that I was in the war
room with the 49ers before at during
their draft during it not after [ __ ]
like in the middle of it and I didn't
take I'm just realizing this I didn't
take one [ __ ] picture the entire town
was there that's what you're supposed to
be like you you're supposed to be like
you I someone the other day was uh I
really am true to like I can't I don't
know I just don't I feel like I'm in and
having an experience and I'm just gonna
have it and I'm gonna walk away like
that and then this special I feel like
at this I long for the old days being a
stand-up comic where you just it was pre
phones you had material come out and
people found it and passed it along to
their friends and now we can give him
the nudge Jay and I certainly am doing
something that you recommend is and
putting [ __ ] on Facebook yeah but I'll
post something on my facebook I always
shoot will shoot a video today post it
opposed to it will [ __ ] posted today
what maybe I don't have been the biggest
turnout for me yeah I'm bad at marketing
myself and that's the other thing is
like why I'm thinking about calling it
quits is because I go to comedy clubs
and I just feel like I've sort of I
haven't got
the people there 200 cent see me it says
this special do that these Showtime
special has been really [ __ ] helpful
like it it's I think if I hadn't this
special might change the scope of my
career in that and I think it performed
mediocre Lee on Showtime but the clips
and it being online and in with the
notoriety of it being like a Showtime
special I think it [ __ ] everyone
found it that's awesome and that's just
and you gotta let you go let people rip
it put it don't let your lawyer to
commit you or your majors to let the
don't let him put it on YouTube let it
put it on YouTube this all can forget
the Me's guys do the most brilliant
thing you put on YouTube it's and then
he just titled it funny naked man
talking and and because I'm shirtless
and it's fun got a ton of views
hey if that Vietnamese guy could do the
same thing for me them up my lawyers are
the number I don't think about like
three times I go stop if you liked funny
naked guy talking what's the name you're
special
it's called shrimpin and easy oh it's
wait did I see a billboard for that I
doubt it no wait I'd be [ __ ] shocked
and not long I long for the times where
um where stand-up wasn't about promoting
yeah I hate like someone said to me
what about should you be on comic my
advice would be are you interested in
starting a production company yeah
because that is what you're starting
you're not just doing stand-up anymore
you are you need to learn Photoshop
because you got a oh man can you ace and
put it on Gilligan's if you ace if you
were a young comedian please take a
social media marketing class right now
take a you need to be a digital marketer
you need to also have some [ __ ] great
desktop skills or your best friend or us
because they may be that oh be Photoshop
godlike like oh I'm amazed at all the
[ __ ] hats I wear like just a crime a
little obsessive-compulsive so I won't
let people
shoot Bibles you everything myself so I
want to be able to like if something
goes wrong I want to go to fix it on I
take blame for it but but yeah I this
past weekend is the best I've ever done
and stand-up in a very long honest
Calgary Aleutian it was because I was
hanging out with Dan all day all that
like we'd go to lunch at noon and we
could stay there till 4:00 and I just
talked I went [ __ ] man I'm this is what
I miss about the one thing I miss about
New York is sitting outside the comedy
club with comics no one's looking at the
phone I mean this isn't unachievable now
but we would just sit out there and
[ __ ] and just break balls
patrisse [ __ ] one of the best parts
about stand-up comedy is the hang yeah
and with hanging out with comics The
Comedy Store is this sort of secret back
bar place it's fantastic I'm gonna be
there more night yeah and you were you
at the store this week I didn't call in
because I have too much it's crazy it's
a shooting a pilot that's yelling it's
like other ass let's let's just real
quick how many [ __ ] things you have
going on right now you've got your
special coming I have no joke this is
there's a list and I'm I could run
through everything but it's a little too
crazy I have made a list with Rachel
Garcia it's 29 and I'm not even joking I
can do that so funny is that the people
were tweeting after did this 49ers thing
and so he's like this guy hasn't done
anything in [ __ ] three years how does
he get a chance to which is like I'd I
don't need to I don't reply to anything
really that's what this guy's doesn't
get three years the [ __ ] of mine well it
simply no idea how many how many
succumbs you've been on this is it I'm
dying up here as number ten Wow and the
more of those have gone to air and about
a boy went to season two and then I did
daily show for five and a half years you
did it with jugs doll John's to you and
then and you then now you're doing I'm
dying up here which is it comes out on
June 4th it's a show about stand-up in
the 70s I love that I was dude I love
that there's a crazy [ __ ] time if
people don't know what we're talking
about there's a book by the same name
and that's what the option
Jim Carrey basically starts showing up
at the Comedy Store and cast a bunch of
us I got put in it and Eric Griffin's in
it Santino's in it and she's my favorite
twitter name by the way to defend you my
favorite Twitter I just met him the
other night literally I think I probably
met him or I've run into him but I just
made like a formal introduction where I
was like seen on the podcast no he's
coming on in a couple weeks
oh great I think no yeah yeah he's
coming on a couple weeks to talk about
I'm dying up here to write or no no I
think we're just doing a blog post I
thought we will definitely talk about
I'm dying up here but uh yeah that's I'm
really looking forward to that show you
Eric Chito uh and then Joe Dom is in it
or else cackles integer ons in it Judy
gold is in it I'm just running down the
comics as far as actor is Melissa Leo
who's in the fighter she won the Oscar
for best actress writer and Jim Carrey
produces and then just to [ __ ] a little
great actress Clark Duke and Michael
anger on Oh Michael anger on oh you just
you look that up it's just a huge what's
the premise of um dying up here like
what is how do how are they structuring
it is it around the strike it's the
whole she will lead up to that but it's
the stand-up comedy scene in LA in 1973
Richard Pryor and right next to him a
guy who could not afford a sandwich and
it was sleeping in his car who was just
as funny and that was like just
desperation of you only had three
different outlets in terms of networks
for stand-up Johnny Carson said could
make you famous and everyone was
fighting to get on all these other shows
midnight special and stand-up was became
a huge thing and stand-up comedians got
to go on all these shows but then on the
Sunset Strip you had drugs everywhere
[ __ ]
you know trainee or hookers [ __ ] run
around and it was a as you said that I
thought you know it's interesting is our
social media presence our marketing are
the way we're doing it is simply a a
reaction to the fact that there were
only a few outlets for comics for a long
time and then comics are Dane just for
like [ __ ] it I'll make my own path yeah
and
and which is perfect you know leads to
what is taking a majority of my [ __ ]
time is all things calm all things
comedy that's my that's my label and so
we click your click I'm going to
announce this here and I just what I
actually texted you because it's like
are you around I wanted I need to talk
to you about something we just got some
money I just got a lot of it really yeah
and we're all things comedy is getting
his website redone right now we're going
to start making video I got that email
from Oscar about all the thing the up
they are yeah it's going down its wagon
and this is something I've been talking
about for years and something me and
bill bird came up with and I've been
busy with all this other [ __ ] but really
trying to nurture this company along
because we should own all over own
content we just distribute all of our
own content you know like there's comedy
dynamics and all these comedy club
owners and we're just everyone's getting
[ __ ] so hard you have no idea how much
a creator gets [ __ ] because you can
there's a big reward at the end of this
when they know that you're the decision
you know you're calling shots and you're
Kevin Hart things are fantastic if you
are you were in demand and you have
multiple suitors good for you yeah but
if you're a very funny comic and you've
got middling success just because it's
just you know dice man you get a Netflix
special dice like that yet cast as Ariel
I'm so I can dice come up Leslie Jones
is tolling around for a long [ __ ]
time before you know she got on to SNL
so we have a tons of comics that were
friends with do we know her hilarious
I'm going to name a couple like we're
going to do news Michael Kosta I think
is one of the funniest [ __ ] dudes
I've ever come across
you know and he doesn't have anything
radio and so anyway we just want to
start making [ __ ] and we the most talked
about things everyone always asked me is
when's that cooking show coming out
there people you guys yes I should I
said look what I just want to say
straight to camera oh yeah we did a
cookie show called something's burning
with Burt
and we had recipe ideas that we were
trying to concoct couldn't find any of
the ingredients I finally talked to his
buddies a chef was Carl Yakko ruies the
guys Karlie's the mad Cuban [ __ ] we
were just on the phone as I was walking
around a Korean supermarket he's like
put this in your cart okay go find some
of this go fight own us and he helped me
make a sauce my wife had the idea for
the sauce I by the way you know can I
tell you this I made those nachos for my
family the next next night without the
fish without the fish I made those not
those exact I had the rest of the pork
butt and I had the things I made this
and everyone [ __ ] lost their mind it
was great so we made a show called
something's burning and Tom and Bill
were stoked because they were in and out
Bert
hilarious not a sanitary cook not a
sanitary but I showed it to Leeanne and
because they we have a it's not even a
stringer we just have a straight shot of
it oh they state sent you so I didn't I
haven't seen that even oh yeah
our Senator Lee Anne when she said she
goes uh typically and she goes don't get
it you're not a cook I go yeah I know
she was what I said yeah how many times
did you laugh she was I laughed
hysterically so that's what it is just
comic hanging out yeah look who gives a
[ __ ] I hope you learned something about
shoes she I go if you learned something
about cooking fantastic but really it's
just [ __ ] fun you know what the
takeaway because that is that sauce yeah
yeah that's takeaway is that sauce so
it's just so easy to make but uh anyway
so that's the thing it said no other
cooking show would have the universal
Alma Cobham going on and then we shot
comedians playing poker I want to figure
out that's good I'll send you a link
yeah the four of us still know how to
play poker I got drunk before we started
like you're not I'm not the drunk you
are I'm right I quiet up like laughing
everybody Bobby Lee and Bill have it to
watch the show just for the relationship
that Bobby Lee has with Bill burr is
worth it alone yeah they have a weird
thing
I captured it a while ago in the green
room and it started when Bill first
moved to LA he came into the comedy
story and he's in the Comedy Store and
Bill overheard Bobby and bill even know
this I mean Bobby didn't know this but
Bill over her Bobby say I don't want
bill to want to follow bill burr because
he was a poppin yeah and then walked up
to Bill and said when you're going up
and bill looked in the make you little
[ __ ] rat you already know when I'm
going up piece of [ __ ] like the pocket
you just talk to the guy about it over
her I [ __ ] the men you gonna come ask
me like just like an a it's just
immediately in Bill does the same thing
I do which is go straight to dead to me
yeah like one little character [ __ ] up a
little snake move like that ooh
dead he told me about one I won't share
it but I was I was like yeah I'm sure I
know yeah I think you know it and I just
like he's like that though he's he's an
increase he's a regular person yeah you
know so and that's the other thing that
brings us back to where we started in
the first place is just with all this
stuff going on and when you have kids
and stand up and that's another thing
that I'm sure you see because you have
two lovely girls and what you're sucking
so big or some at the Comedy Jam table
ever sitting over to my right Jesus
Christ
I'm so [ __ ] oh and I'm having a
problem with them getting up getting
older like it's just I'm like one I want
to start all over
I want to have a new family I want
babies again I have an 11 year old girl
yeah and it almost 15 year old son
Lorenzo came over the house we had a
birthday party
we just had something come up for
Valentine's Day that made me very
worried about what's going down because
one of the families came up nice family
yeah and add a big heart-shaped See's
candy box but you know if you have a kid
they do Valentimes just like when we
were a little you get the ones you buy
you write the names on them my wife goes
reward I'm married half Korean Martha
Stewart who makes her own online if I
couldn't does a thing it's got theme
every gets unique she out moms everybody
I can't explain the ass and so delivered
everyone gets the same thing five girls
in the fifth grade got special gifts one
dude who looks like Danny Zuko brought
[ __ ] a girl of teddy bear nice one
plush and then another guy brought
something else and something else so
they at all would collusion for me
because they all picked girls yeah and
my daughter got again a $30 box of C's
yeah the note says from and then the
lady hands to my wife this is from the
family wink wink
there are 11 year old girls yeah so I go
to the teacher and I color over and I go
you hear about all these special gifts
she goes no I go yeah five different
special gifts I said you can teach him
5th grade for a long time has this ever
happened before and she goes not at all
no precedent it I don't know what's
happening well this is too soon yeah you
better get a handle on it
oh I walked like it's like I'm going to
fix the problem today had to call all
the boys in telling me he's the [ __ ] up
yeah because see people start picking
girls like I don't want my daughter to
have like some dude you know especially
at 10 and 11 is too much is sooo crazy
Oh what my older one is no phone yet
though right no there are they both are
phones
what yeah they both have phones why Wow
no reason you can't give me a reason I
don't know they look good I gotta get a
hold of them no you don't you borrow
everyone borrow phone yeah if there's a
problem call at like 4 o'clock to pick
her up from school she'll call you
should be like I'm ready I've got
cooking class I'm ready yeah and got
them both phone they both have phones
and then are they on apps are they on to
snapchat we just had a real big
shakedown
because I posted a video to promote um
Calgary show mm-hmm and uh and it was me
working on the back then I walk away and
I got yeah yeah and all my kids friends
are on Facebook and Instagram and my
wife's like you got to take it down I
was like no just get them to [ __ ] not
follow me like how come why is it like
they shouldn't be in the world like that
they shouldn't be seeing things like
that but like I'm doing it because it's
funny and that's what I do for a living
and so Leanne's like yeah I guess you're
right I mean I don't it just sucks it
like now you're in a place in life where
I guess that's why you don't have kids I
guess it's you know well that's where we
have a lot of friends that don't have
kids and their lives are
you know so interesting that you know
comics can just hang out all night you
know in terms of something they can do
all that [ __ ] they could post anything
want they can say anything they want I
have this fifteen-year-old son where I
know for a fact that was happening and I
anticipated it was happening and I even
then I don't talk about it really any
sex stuff in my act I swear in my act
whatever but I just like I don't talk
about my wife in a gross way or I'd like
that
I used it actually I used to I before I
was aware of it I had a joke about how
my wife at post second kids she
breastfed now her tits like one looks
like a man's wallet and the other one
looks like a leather satchel you might
see at a Renaissance Fair after was
dropped by a falcon at a high altitude
and pocket like and I do yeah oh yeah
beat it and I can't you know now my kids
have access to this thing but they're
you know what they're not that
interested yeah that's the interesting
thing is that they really do I kids
could give two shits about Georgia said
to me about my special she said hey can
I watch your special I was like I think
to a part so I watched the beginning of
it and immediately she's like yo his I
Latinas talking about island I'm talking
about isla right now I love my new hour
I have 22 minutes about her like and I'm
like I got to cut it down so that it's
not just an act about this one child
that must be different I make fun of my
in this special non-stop because my son
it was a good athlete but now he came
like a mediocre athlete because everyone
got huge and he's just yeah I said
scored 34 points in a basketball game
once really yeah at 10 years old
don't [ __ ] with Lorenzo like he was bad
it's like he just school people made all
the shots he was the guy everyone grew
he did not confidence got shot and now
he's actually picking it up again like
this kid I want to go play with them the
other day made eight three-pointers in a
row just really dropping like Steph
Curry saw so much better shaped by the
Sun like a [ __ ] douche it's all the
time with them you do my daughter plays
a club volleyball you should go to
heaven do [ __ ] like that my daughters
are so [ __ ] lazy really only thing
they do is softball we go out in the
front yard and with wiffle balls and
we'll play volleyball net oh that's a
bad man with a black diamond every day
that's the worst volleyball night I've
ever seen and as I was badminton intent
see our badminton is uh but my daughters
are even horrible at that we're just
uncoordinated it's funny Iowa's ila
today rut were riding their bikes to
school and she [ __ ] ran into you know
yeah like you hit rearview mirrors of
your car yeah Hollywood I like it with a
bike handle I think that drunken college
[ __ ] me up so you talk about that you
talk about hitting the bike and you talk
about them being weird knock we're down
there watching this special and you know
my son I invited him to come with me to
the special and he had to do something
else he's like I can't go and he didn't
care yeah so I don't know I don't give a
[ __ ] about mentioning them too much or
other Hollywood kids are there any
actors at your kids school Renta zzs
kids that's it really you moved too
that's why I live in Pasadena I love
your house because we don't want there
to be my wife has this thing where she
says I love our school because we're the
biggest [ __ ] there you know we don't
I don't want my kids too happy with any
other actor kids
there's not many I don't think there's
many in our school
I don't think so when you go the problem
is is that you go to some of these
schools and they're dying and like keep
up with you know Steve Carell kids yeah
they flew him on a plane and they went
to go see a Knicks game in Madison since
about whatever it's like yeah I can't
compete with a member elisabeth porter
yeah those who ran Comedy Central for a
long time I took a meeting with the
other day and she was like oh she was
talking about they have a kid her and
her husband her husband's a strong
writer and she's like I go do you guys
have it a live in Silver Lake
I could you guys have any other actors
she goes oh my god and listed off the
[ __ ] writers that all do drop off
they do like safety ballet and I was
like I couldn't go to that school I'd be
so [ __ ] intimidated yeah I'd be like
the whole time I'd be like no but I just
don't want my kid to keep and compete
with their kids I don't want my kids to
yeah they grow up too fast I think I
don't want my kids doing blow at 13
either at half you know how like that
Rihanna half shaved head thing Oh like
I'm not doing that
I want my kids to have normal
backgrounds and then they can just rebel
against whatever they want their life is
already too weird you know they do
they'll come over and like a Christmas
party is like you Rory Scovel you know
like all these you know just comedy
friends and people are all [ __ ]
around they'll see everybody on TV and
they don't even think anything of it and
I think that's strange
that's another thing I saw my daughter's
love this show good luck charlie and uh
and so that I'm having birth conquerors
or I think premiering or triplet one
episodes premiering wherever the
premiere party and the dad from good
luck charlie shows up to the thing it's
like blonde yeah yeah who's the one in
true romance I'm shot man
and so I said dude I go do you mind oh I
got to introduce you to my daughters
he's like I don't mind so I go girls
come over here and so there's my buddy I
want to introduce you and they're like
yeah I go all right and then Georgia
goes we'll be done and I was like yeah
so I go okay and leave so I go over
there I go hey you do that you want to
show them [ __ ] yeah he goes yes
- definitely luck charlie I said yeah
aren't you like and you want to say
something she goes no I won't you
impress the guy
your favorite showed us today she was
dad he's just on TV it's not a big deal
I was like holy [ __ ] you have like [ __ ]
same exact thing is that I'm so anyway I
like having kids and doing stand-up
comedy it's it really is a young even
though you see all these old comics yeah
it's a young man's game but it to go out
and [ __ ] be out on Tuesday and just
do it so [ __ ] hard how do you do it
I talked to Fitzsimmons about it
Fitzsimmons like no I just I don't wake
up until noon or until 10:00 the kids go
to school he goes I'm a comic I stay out
at night that's my job obviously I don't
do that I don't do that either I call in
sparingly like I will call in I'll do
Tuesday nights if that but if I'm on the
road I won't work that week like I'm
really hard how do you do it I wake up I
just take a lot of vitamin b12 Rogan
told me that I told him I was getting
tired in the afternoons and he thinks I
have a vitamin D deficiency because we
got me taken like a multivitamin around
3 p.m. every day yeah and yeah I just
really tried if I can go for it and I
don't that's a day other thing is I
don't sleep in till 10:00 I don't take
[ __ ] naps what's your day look like
what would what time you wake up so I
woke up today at 5:45 in the morning I
have a son to wake up who has to make it
to a bus by 6:40 so I know he likes to
sleep in until like 6:10 6:05 so I start
turning on lights make coffee usually do
wipe up my wife is up will switch but
the latest purse is a the last person to
get up gets up at 7 a.m.
I've extra dollar and no that's yeah
that's my daughter and we're up like the
whole house is up by 7 a.m. every single
day really so then kids have to go to
the bus kids have to go to school my
daughter needs to be dropped off by 8:00
then what I'll try to do if I have a
free day I couldn't do it this morning
as I'll go to the gym 8:30 to 9:30 go to
this Pasadena gym with all these
Lululemon moms yeah and people make fun
but I'd rather work out it's like it's
really really attractive rich Pasadena
women and that's the
that's I work out with them and then I
start so I'll be writing or working by
10:00 a.m. every single day writing what
are you like writing a script writing
jokes no not writing jokes ever I wish
if I was writing jokes every single day
at 10:00 a.m. everyone would know about
it because I'd have a comedy special
every single [ __ ] year and I would be
one of the most prolific comics of all
time
I barely write stand up stand up is he
on that list of 29 things yeah like
hitting 20 at this point like it's a
brutal so that's why this special is
like a collection of three and a half
years of bits like there's not so I'm
not one of those dudes who's great I've
thrown on an hour away to get to this
hour
yeah and so yeah this is the best of
three and a half years of work I see I
just took my list I want to I want to
keep going with your list but I gotta
leave my list and I shaved it down and I
just put three things on it
where are your three things podcast
stand up um scripted one one scripted
show okay and then but then I just sold
a couple non-scripted ideas and so and
so I'm now I'm lying a little bit but
but I really for a moment I was just
shaved it down because I was like I was
like I really we got wood something's
burning on there something's burning
ozone is on that list by the way I'm
keep meaning to call Oscar with notes
but uh but that I feel like when my list
gets too heavy like when I was a Travel
Channel I was losing my [ __ ] money I
didn't know what it was like to relax
oh I don't uh yeah I bought a bunch of
Jack Reacher books and I'm reading a
book right now called the cartel but Don
Winslow's which is really good I highly
recommend these Don Winslow's books but
I have to have these books to force
myself to go you were at my place at
night yeah see my place during the day
I'll show you a picture we have a
backyard
that I have I have three hammocks I
don't lay in your house is [ __ ]
fantastic yeah well I have I would never
or else I would have all the stuff I
made like a little vacation place in my
backyard yeah and I don't spend any time
back there I also like to garden I like
to [ __ ] around in the backyard and I
don't do that at all so I have to force
myself to read to know this settle down
anyway so I shoot this is what I got
going on this week I talk like you're
writing then 10 o'clock I'm writing I
have a movie that I've written that I'm
fixing up a monde raft number to do well
it's really like draft number four right
now yeah I wrote that with Kevin Kristy
but we're actually trying to get it
produced and that's like a Mexican
Breakfast Club type of thing set in El
Paso yeah and so I'm doing that I have a
TV show I've had a deal and is you know
stand-up comedians and writers you get
network development deals and so this is
maybe I had deal number seven last uh
last year I thought I had a lot of deals
that sevens a [ __ ] dick load yeah
it's crazy because all of those deals
are from my own Everybody Loves Raymond
type of show too so I've written I have
seven different pilot scripts and more
that are specs for my own show that I
think are legitimately good like I got
told by Les Moonves uh you know two
years ago what a great writer I was and
that keeps the decision maker and how
far my script went in this process of 40
and then you know matt LeBlanc is going
to get the show over me because I really
you know I'm not a known name so I'll go
[ __ ] crazy in this business that you
can work as much as you have and people
still go oh it's bigger than anything
yeah yeah yeah like you are them but you
are the busiest dude I know I shoot a
pilot in Mexico next week that I created
and executive producing for Comedy
Central
really yeah it's Robert Byrne oh yeah
sure is a travel show with Chris read
Jack Knight and Josh Johnson it's red
Chris red is the pop star yeah oh yeah
oh he's great and then
night is young super charming funny
black comic and then Josh Johnson
Tonight Show writer but hilarious just
taped half hours I think all three of
the guys just did half hours all black
central yes
and what do you would what's the show
it's it's called travel show we don't
really have the title but it's called
travel show it's not it's thing three
guys are just showing up in a city and
things not going according to plan like
it's a travel show but they it's more
about their relationships and then what
it is it's a travel show so you're going
to see a different city every single
week yeah but to see three young very
different black friends that brings you
like you know a whole swingers vibe to
the whole thing that's like the one's a
Vince Vaughn type once it's John you
know yeah never she got a guy and they
have a great time
oh that's [ __ ] awesome yeah so we do
Cabo San Lucas Mike Lawrence is the head
writer on that Mike Lawrence
oh yeah I don't know the rest is a
[ __ ] joke but we shiny money and them
to be on the podcast
well he's busy he just got another
writing gig but keeps a welcome blow it
also and then to movie TV show just met
with writers and producers last week
because I have another TV show idea that
they really like and so then we'll go
and chop that around I'm working with
James Corden people on my own show I'm
going to talk about yeah yeah I got a
really good idea for a weekly a talk
show is that the other thing is like
every Daily Show person went and
graduated into their own show I went
directly into a sitcom which is awesome
yeah forth lead on a sitcom is the best
thing ever
yeah because what and that's what I
think you should do more acting how are
you do I have a scripted deal that we're
doing I think we should be shooting in
August I think we just we were just
breaking the story's right now yeah and
and and that's I really don't like I
don't want to be now I say this but I
think I'm wrong about this I don't think
I want to be like this I want to be the
star of a show and I want it to be about
me and I wanted to
my creative vision like I don't want to
just get plugged into an acting role oh
it's not me man
I go my dream is to draw up all of this
[ __ ] and just be the sixth or seventh to
eat on an NCIS where I wear a lab coat
and I'm like ethnic lab rap yeah I go
you guys aren't going to like this and
[ __ ] go catching and [ __ ] go sit
in that back yard and read a Jack
Reacher and have a [ __ ] Booker's oh I
see my problem is my problem is a number
one i when I was doing travel 10 I
thought I was really happy and then it
turns out I wasn't I mean I was very
happy I really enjoyed it if you are to
everyone listening and people that know
you you do seem like the happiest guy of
all time no matter what your situation
is I did I have hardcore FOMO so like as
I was doing Travel Channel I kept
thinking to myself I wish I was I wish I
was at the store I wish I was at the
improv I wish I was I wish I was still
plugged in and then when I stopped doing
it I started I started really focusing
on my stand-up and I was like I [ __ ]
forgot I love this I forgot that I
really truth when you when you break a
joke like like it's one thing to get an
idea and to get it kind of up and
running but then when you break a joke
and you go oh [ __ ] I figured it out
I figured it out I that happened to me
this weekend and I was so inspired like
last time you seen you like watch the
Rogen set of last Tuesday us because
that bit that he has about the woman who
got impregnated without the no vagina no
I wasn't even a bit dude I told him
afterwards cuz I have a little bit of
comedy snob also like for snob and you
see a lot of people you guys that are
super successful that have no business
don't belong doing stand-up at home yeah
I went through watching bunch of Netflix
specials this weekend and was like oh
dude you shouldn't be doing stand-up you
just memorize the cadences of testing
and oh kinda like so
many people that should not be doing
stand-up that I'm blown the [ __ ] away or
Superbikes it that's another thing it's
like I'm being [ __ ] baby about this
but it's a little disheartening for
somebody who's like I have a line about
this it's like I feel like stand-up is
my life's calling and it's difficult for
me to admit that it's somebody else's
last resort like there's a lot of people
doing stand-up that's a really brutal
sadness yet well but it's somebody
else's last resort like you're like oh
just like if you stand up I good and so
it's a cash grab for some people and
it's and by the way I've got in a lot of
trouble doing that st. John [ __ ] that's
my favorite thing about you is that you
I remember hearing you talk [ __ ] on
Rogen's podcast a long time ago yeah
just lighten [ __ ] up and you're
like [ __ ] that guy is a thief [ __ ] this
what oh yeah I remember going like [ __ ]
for me my casa that's another thing is I
have the balls to go up and talk to
people right to their face I'll never do
anything on Twitter that's what [ __ ]
if you are on tweeting at somebody and
not putting the ad symbol directly to
their thing or tweeting you're talking
some [ __ ] to about people like say it to
their face that's another thing it's
people have done the @ thing and [ __ ]
talk some [ __ ] somebody tweeted al
Madrigal you can look this up I got it's
retweeted then pin it
pussy-ass wannabe comic [ __ ] sand
[ __ ] I'm a half Mexican
I was like what are you living yeah you
come find me
yeah and you say it to my face oh dude
and I love it and I won't read laughs
but like what can have some balls but
you're [ __ ] tweeting [ __ ] and talking
[ __ ] they come talk [ __ ] to my face and
then I'll respect I don't [ __ ] like
is that someone would think that you you
literally are you are the you were the
guy that I heard the most about when I
first came like when I first started
doing the road well we have a lot in
common because we found each other
yeah I don't even want to get into it uh
that uh you know what the man
oh yeah a name was but all that reserve
we bonded probably over that and then
became buddies and like him Ben you were
the fault you were the funniest guy I
remember watching yourself we did that
showcase in San Jose
oh yeah I was like I was like this this
is the funny I got about that [ __ ]
comic I've ever seen and ever and I
remember sit in the back with someone
they're like oh I was like toured with
Mitch toured with Chappelle tour with
everything I was like [ __ ] man how do I
get that good and I remember I remember
you had a joke that I had bit that had
been in front of my face and I didn't
right and I went [ __ ] this the [ __ ] in
the Russian or the Russian kids in the
sandbox or me as Santa a repo man yeah
because when your kids are playing in
the park and then you bring a bunch of
sand toys and you put them down if
anybody has little tiny kids you know
this is very true please your sand toys
down and then people take them and
people dig and you're like yeah
everybody enjoy them exactly when you're
ready to go you got to be Santa a repo
man and go like hey I need that shovel
back buddy is my shovel it's my shovel a
bigger grave I'll be ok Armenian baby I
think I think of I think of your joke I
think of your jokes sometimes the looks
like he's not gonna look like it what's
the burking joke okay he's not gonna
have it his way
yeah oh [ __ ] that's an old bit I like in
LA but you're sincerely one of the best
and that's working like no you know that
you're one of the best stands for you if
you didn't have 29 things on your list
and you wrote jokes every single day
you're right you would be the greatest
stand-up that we'd ever known I did not
say that but yeah but if you worked at
this it really sure like you would be
prolific and I didn't care if there was
an audience for it or not I would just
be putting out albums and that's the
other thing it's like that's what I can
do and I when I say I'm going to quit
like I'm really not going on the road I
do a ton of corporate stand-up here once
you get paid thirty thousand dollars to
do a gig at 3:30 in the afternoon
there is no going back Oh God - with
your seen a party - stand up
yeah I love him he's [ __ ] hilarious
and he was like we were talking we were
talking I love when comics talk numbers
because it allows you to realize where
you are in the business and what you
need to get to you know like and he was
telling us what he gets paid for his
corporates and I was like I don't know
if I'd ever do the road I go why are you
doing the [ __ ] road and he was like
like I you got to you got to keep it you
got to keep as do as much of different
things you got to do the clubs you got
to the road you got to do the corporates
give you Jeff do the corporates he's
like I can't just do corporate so I was
like do you eat it a gig they flew him
to [ __ ] Asia to be on a yacht with
the owner of the Seahawks I guess what
and like he opened on this yacht I mom I
don't know if I should be telling his
story I'm sure he's like hey bird I told
you that in privacy like don't share
that no but is echo through Fallon I
mean that's for like every mother
someone else who Fallon loves him he's
one of the greatest stand-ups and they
to have access to those types of gigs
you plant yourself in some weird
situations yeah he opened for Stevie
Wonder on this yacht Stevie Wonder it
was him and the Stevie Wonder ladies and
gentlemen skate for Stevie Wonder I did
a gig before the Super Bowl the lineup
was Jeremy Renner me and the Steve
Miller Band what did Jeremy Renner do -
had a couple drinks just talked he hos
he was the host shut up he's like hey
guys yeah he's like you know they used
to seal on the Avengers and Hurt Locker
and I should impossible and every other
huge franchise and now I needed your
host I did one corporate one I've done
one corporate and it was and I'd fallen
off that waterfall and I was on oxys and
Valium and at one point one of the guys
in the thing goes hey man just tell the
Machine story so I was like really goes
yeah we just just tailed machine story
in the let's go drink they just wanted
me to tell the Machine story and then go
party with the Menashe Minh they flew me
to Aspen
put me up in Aspen paid [ __ ] read it
and and then they were like they go tell
the Machine story like I was doing bits
and the guy goes you're gonna tell them
machines right I was like yeah he was
just telling them will go drink I was
like done
told the machine story came in they
asked a bunch of questions about it and
just drank with them all night
Wow who's the [ __ ] greatest yeah I do
a lot of corporate hosting I was
Viacom's host for a while do as I did
all these Viacom conferences they paid
incredibly well and then to go do you
know a [ __ ] funny bone after that
where I have a $5,000 guarantee not
gonna happen I'm not going to do it
because I'd rather hang out with Mike
you know I went to a volleyball
tournament all day yesterday and sat
there with the you know talk [ __ ] with
the other dads and I just well it
doesn't make sense it I mean it doesn't
make sense because the amount of money
you make doing all your other things you
don't need that [ __ ] fiber and I love
them when stand up so you could sort of
pull a Fitzsimmons you can go to as you
look at Fitzsimmons and how he's able to
sort of do a lot of different things
yeah and he still does way more Road
than I would like but I also act more
than he does and I feel like I have
different stuff going on also being an
actor on a TV show it's like you're
being like a little [ __ ] Prince
somewhere it's like would you like me to
bring you they just put out some tuna
salad and chicken salad in there do you
want me to bring you a smoothie huh is
something only sick I've ever worked on
was my feel like right when I first got
out here I got putting a sitcom fun CBS
and uh and it was like I remember I
didn't realize what I was doing but I
was like I said to the craft service I
was like hey there's a little corn dogs
yeah yesterday it was really good and
then you watch this I didn't realize
that he's like I'll go get them and then
he had to go and get more corn dogs for
me like we went to the store and bought
those little corn dogs and came back and
they had them and he was like you want
me to bring them in new dressing room
and I'm like oh no I was just asking you
add them and he was like no no I went
and got them I was like oh my god oh
yeah anything they did a show in 2007
with Raquel Welch and Jeffrey Tambor
called welcome to the captain yeah I
think of that every time I Drive through
a large spot yeah we're not building
dude I've been on so many shows you have
no idea like I had a show in 2003 this
is the one that brought me down here but
Cheech played my dad I was number one on
culture I was supposed to be what was
that
it was called the Ortega
and we shot 12 of all we shot six they
were supposed to be 12 I was wearing a
pilgrims outfit but time to go get out
of here no I don't have any good now
that's I don't have any time I have to
get out of here I'm fine
so I'm in a pilgrims outfit it was an
improvised talk shows based on a British
show and my slot was I was following the
Simpsons Sunday night November 4th of
2003 and they cancelled it and didn't
air any of them really yeah so I have
this I have actually have them you know
what I need to find that Vietnamese guy
I'm gonna send him all of the shows and
he can post them all oh I feel like
telling people hey guys rip everything I
do and post it
yeah someone I'll go get you the [ __ ]
title so I'm in a sitcom that no one's
ever seen before that we have shot and
the only tapes that exist of it or in my
living room like I have a bunch of CDs I
should start posting full a bale of
failed pile of all Drive so many [ __ ]
pill bottles yeah I've so many I told I
have I have full episodes of the ex show
maybe I'll just post the sample episodes
I was out a pilot with Martin Short who
I played his secretary and I what was
that that was a show called the IRS and
it was an IRS office in Akron and it was
me Martin Short Debbie I was like a
subject or character was Martin Short
Kerri Kenney from the stage yes she's
[ __ ] hilarious reno911.com Holt's Al
and Orlando Jones Judy Greer Randall
Park the dead who is the fresh off the
boat is very funny comic and Matt Moy
who's in two Broke Girls and even some
more people was a huge sewer ensemble
Castle [ __ ] and dad nothing not like no
play at all oh I have so many I have so
many [ __ ] pilots I want to get all my
pilot's all get my manager we get all
get all my pilots and
put them all online yes why not like who
gives a [ __ ]
not anymore I think that sort of
changing as I get I think there should
be a whole TV network they could never
do this because they have to pay for
rights real scenario like that would
cost them a lot of money but there
should be a whole TV network dedicated
to one off some pilots and shows no
one's ever seen before
yeah I'm [ __ ] I I mean now it's like
now I feel things are so easy when you
have an idea you can just go shoot it
like something's burning we were walking
through the soap box thing and you know
they're like really kitchen area shoot
something
I bet something's burning so many
[ __ ] times to realnetworks
like they're going let's do this and
then everyone's like I don't get it
you're not a chef and I was like that
who gives a [ __ ] yeah yeah vigorous
manner give every chef anybody's
everybody's a chef nowadays nowadays
every [ __ ] we mean you're not a chef
you look at the Food Network and you
have that hot chick from Reno not and I
will not read another one as Beverly
Hills 90210 I would simply introducing
yeah she's a chef we are they do that I
was one of the Queen watching the food
the one thing I'm trying to avoid in my
life is I'm obsessed with this right now
the people that are in this business
where celebrity is the reason they're
there because they don't really have a
passion for whatever the [ __ ] that's the
other thing that comes down to stand up
and this is going to bring us full
circle is that there's a certain amount
of desperation that goes along with I
need to do podcast I need to do this
because everyone else is doing and I
need to give what there's nothing that
really drives it you know and there's
none like if you to do stand-up I really
feel like it has to be like this calling
you know that your feel is an artist
like somebody doesn't pick up a
paintbrush because they think it's going
to get them noticed you know you feel
like you're joking this innate that your
are there are no painters that are in it
for the fame yeah but there's so many
comics were just in it to get famous yep
I bet if you gave them Fame they'd
probably stop doing stand-up you know
you should go back and listen to you
heard of a
horrible I just got it this is why I
need to maybe walk away is that what
killed Tony's oh yeah just to mean I
just stopped hey this guy's done 30
seconds some girl Hobbs I think I didn't
kill Tony the other day and some girl
goes um I said something she goes I
didn't get in this business to do bit
dot dot and I go honey
I didn't get in this business for [ __ ]
blooded in the airport at 6:00 a.m. but
that's part of the digital area
it's do you have blood coming out I did
once now I have a lot really yeah
from what I think it's hemorrhoids I
fell off an aircraft carrier
and I was [ __ ] blood and I thought
I'd ruptured internal organs or
something and I'd go in he fingers my
ass and he's like no you ruptured a
hemorrhoid miss hemorrhoids I was like
really happy yeah
thanks yeah I knew we should not have
horrible problem Belenko once every two
months
no gonna be some black Bob bigger staff
has my favorite joke I've ever ever
heard he goes this is I'm [ __ ] it up
I'm sorry Bob if you're listening he's
got a podcast called hell hello guys
enjoy guys is this vodka um his joke is
this is how I wipe brown brown brown red
stop if its image has a great joke about
[ __ ] [ __ ] watching some like
vegan [ __ ] yo just comes out smoothly
looks like he's got one leg up shaking
because he goes first two wives I don't
even look at those yeah I know every
wife I don't even look at us yeah dude
that's a soda and I were doing this
weekend
we're just quoting our favorite a tell
jokes aloud he had this joke about that
L said about pandas I forget what the
joke was never not pandas koalas ah [ __ ]
I love the asides from Mattel when I was
going watch it's like the punch silent
he would show up and he would do monkey
put a monkey [ __ ] to get now you're
back like them
my rug and he would make fun of people
in the audience he would do it so um I'd
loved when he called out he would
nickname audience members and I sitting
there he's like where you going Asian
jazz man hey he said one time I was
walking through the back of the comedy
store and he goes and I was wearing a
Hawaiian shirt he goes this is by the
way this is just to play it this was in
1997 so he goes uh yeah only two things
wear Hawaiian shirts party animals and
[ __ ] yes he's the bugger best big
totally great Astoria slit about Adele
apparently is like Nate and soda or
standing next to a towel and this drunk
guy comes up he's like [ __ ] [ __ ]
tousle with him he's like hey I love you
man I love you damn I love you like
shaking him and you think I love you
and David was great let me introduce you
to my two friends stands by and watches
it happen oh [ __ ] it it tells about yeah
I wanna get him on my podcast
um he's he's harder well I mean you can
now sort of visualize everything you
want to have happen you could chart out
the career you want for yourself Rogan
this perfect example of that sort of is
like like me at the Niners the other day
yeah I'm a lifelong Golden State warrior
and 49er fan this is like a dream come
true how did you get in there i roasted
that did a private gig roasted I'd me
and Sodor there's a comics that are 49er
fans like I'm Michael che Dan Soder
Tommy John Egan david huntzberger myself
our big Niner fans yeah I know Carla
sells rocky as well I can't leave him
out and we the four of us went up and
did this rules of engagement thing we
did videos for the Niners yeah but it
was through Steve Simone so Steve simone
used to be in Philly
yeah and work for the Eagles the guy he
worked with at the Eagles who was in
charge they're like shooting some of
their videos went to Kansas City Chiefs
then the Niners hired him
Symone hooked him up with me I started
talking to a month
we became good friends he now became the
vice president of 49ers so and had me do
a gig where I roasted Trent Baalke the
old GM on his 50th birthday so I'm
[ __ ] on Jed York I'm like
everybody's there Tom Rath Ben Trent
Dilfer and I'm just crushing people Jim
Tomsula before he was coach I walked up
and I go keep it going for ron jeremy
everybody and he turns around goes [ __ ]
you
hi Cisco let's get started and I just
hammered people I go Jed York is here
big round pause for Jed he's the owner
of the San Francisco 49ers Oh Jed went
to Notre Dame on a my mom owns a [ __ ]
football team scholarship until people
go nuts yeah and then I made fun of
Colin Kaepernick way while he was still
good and people went and Trent Dilfer in
the back this is like my opening lines
as I knew for a fact that this is way
before any of this news came out Jim
Harbaugh and people people weren't
getting along
yeah so I go Jim Harbaugh couldn't be
here tonight folks before we start a
couple of announcements that's the best
way to start any roast yeah no let me
Jim Harbaugh cannot be here
unfortunately he's on a Disney cruise
we're having on good authority he's
already made goofy cry twice and he also
just tried to sign Peter Pan to the
practice squad as a four string
quarterback which is ridiculous because
we already have Colt McCoy how many
Peter Pan's do we need 10 o'clock in I
hear dopher in the back of holy [ __ ]
this is going to be good and then I go
AJ Jenkins can't be here tonight he's a
bad draft pick little rod receiver that
never worked out and I go he wanted to
come but I got bumped by old lady in the
airport and thrown off his route yeah
and then when he went to get on the
plane they wouldn't let him fly without
an adult and then I go and Colin
Kaepernick can't be here tonight folks
which I'm bummed about Colin really
wanted to come but you see he had a
second option and for the first time in
his entire career he decided to take a
look at it [ __ ] the place went but
all that [ __ ] I mean this is like a
hundreds of agility me I'm the only
comedian there and a couple of his
friends got up and told some stories you
know but then I just [ __ ] hammered
people things went a little south of
anybody's a hockey fan the general
manager of the San Jose Sharks was there
this guy Doug Wilson and I saved him for
last which was a mistake and I should
have just excluded him really because
there's all football guys I had jokes
for Scouts I did an impression of the
trainer like [ __ ] the trainer came up
to me this guy Ferg and he's like hey
buddy that was [ __ ] awesome chewing
at all times yeah I go he goes anything
you need bro I'll I'll take care of it
I'm your guy yeah you want anything
Niner related I will make it happen so I
grew up with this team my dad had
tickets at Khizar Stadium I weighed the
same section with all my buddies in
candlestick growing up I went to every
single game since I was five years old
on really so I've been that that stadium
lived there and then they moved we have
16 tickets at the new stadium and then
all this [ __ ] happen so then I meet Jed
York afterwards I meet everybody
afterwards and then they tell me you
know I go and I do I roasted the NFL
owners before the Superbowl that was the
Jeremy Renner Steve Miller gig oh really
so I was sitting at a table with Robert
Kraft the CEO Pepsi's Robert Kraft is
the owner of the new a tree 'its and les
Moonves right when I had a script with
that with CBS and he was the sole
decision maker like it was insane he was
at the roast he was he was at my table
Jed York the owner of the 49ers goes hey
man he goes I know you got the CBS deal
you want to sit next to Les Moonves and
I go oh sure [ __ ] if the pigs couldn't
get weirder [ __ ] and so that's when I
walked in here nervous dude I was
incredibly nervous because jeremy renner
was on stage and the CEO of Pepsi is
next to me
the woman Indra knew he who's too badass
old what I had no idea is all the
stadium owners all the owners of all
these football teams Billy Ayers we're
all making their rounds by my table and
kissing her ring because she has Pepsi
deals at every single stadium
responsible for giving each of them like
20 million dollars oh wow
so say I and she's a huge Daily Show fan
which I knew she goes she was taking
selfies with me so then people are
saying who the [ __ ] is this guy shut up
yeah so Henry were coming around and
being nice to me see that this blows me
away this you have such a different
career than the majority of comics that
ever will do stand-up like I would be
[ __ ] my pants I was so I'm sitting
next to the this guy Stacey who's the
head of PR for the Patriots and I'm
running some bits bottom and I was going
to go up and do this tooth fairy bit and
he goes buddy nobody wants to hear buy
your kids wait to hear this [ __ ] so
and this is afterwards yeah I do mic bit
it they all can't laugh as much as
they'd like to my biggest laughs come
from people that aren't present like I'm
roasting every almost every single owner
so I get to Woody Johnson from the Jets
who's the owner of the Jets I know
everything yeah and he wasn't there and
I go I'm bummed that Woody Johnson
couldn't be here tonight folks big fan
of his such admirer I mean to achieve so
much success fortune and fame with a
name that really literally translates to
penis penis because all it would the
jokes are sort of softballs that's just
laughs yeah why wasn't there when you I
do my duck Mark Davis Raiders jokes he's
at the table next to him they can't
laugh in his face yeah so I go Mark
Davis is here folks a lot of people
don't know this but Mark also wanted to
move his team to Los Angeles but he
couldn't because his minivan broke down
outside of Gilroy and it just thank you
there he's got the one of the worst
haircuts if you don't know what Mark
Davis the owner of the now Las Vegas
Raiders his hair looks like you got a
look at it it's just a straight-up bowl
cut yeah and I go the closest thing the
Raiders have come to a bull is the one
they put on Mark Davis his head before
his next haircut and [ __ ] like that and
no less really could be sitting right
there and there is that they're all
power brokers yeah the coolest dude came
up to me afterwards the president of the
Chargers he goes dude we go to little
Ohio Comedy Store
all the time because that was [ __ ]
hilarious
me and my wife wanted were dying but you
realize no one could laugh right and
even in the draft room John Lynch she
goes I remember you because we were the
guy that got up and did that roast
because it was one of funniest things
I've ever seen but he goes it was Cory
was like call it a little bit but I got
big laughs here and there Jerry Jones
heckled me I really want ya I go Jerry
Jones is here tonight it goes don't do
it don't even think about it buddy
like that I go Jerry I'm going to do it
it's one joke it's harmless like that
and they were all softballs to because I
listed out my jokes with the president
of the 49ers he goes let me hear him and
I feel like Virginia McCaskey is here
tonight folks the owner of the Bears
yeah she's been with the bears a long
time ever since they were loaded onto
the Ark and Chuck's old lady crazy
that's great so and [ __ ] he goes dude
that's one of the best jokes I heard you
can't do it can't do it at all because
they're all so sensitive so these are
billionaires dirty billionaire's easy
that relate to nothing the I'm standing
there with Rich Eisen and the owner of
the Jacksonville Jacksonville Jaguars
son after clearly conversations I talked
to me jet and Jerry Jones talked for 20
minutes like it just chit-chatting with
your Jones I could have gone to
strippers I could have gone to like zero
many dark places that I just couldn't so
I didn't and then I'm standing there
with this kid from the Jacksonville
Jaguars and he goes man because he did
really good because you did so much
better than the last comedian we had he
was so terrible who he just ate [ __ ]
like who was it because this guy Jim
Gaffigan oh we did material and they
don't relate to anything and the hero or
just anything you're up there talking
about baloney and hot pockets and all
the [ __ ] Jim Gaffigan is one of the
best comedians it exists but they have
such a different they want jokes about
they can't like Willy can talk about
their pilot get in a fight with their
chef okay you can't pausing a fighter
set though you hate it and connect to
you when I did that corporate the lead
girl said to me
all these guys are very wealthy and I
was like okay she's like so like I
talked about your Rolex I'd talk about
like flying first class I was like I
don't I don't write jokes I don't write
like alright so hold that you know what
this is untapped cuz comedy set just do
a set were ultra wealthy people have an
hour that just caters to the ultra
wealthy like a super where billionaire
stand-up comic you could just talk about
[ __ ] they can really my I had a joke the
other day my maid my maid came over and
she's like yeah I'll see you in two
weeks is you know coming next weeks
because now I'm going to Hawaii I was
like what we [ __ ] pain why she called
a bucket a white lily has like yeah I
don't think what the [ __ ] and then we
got our gardener went to [ __ ] well he
went to Mexico but he went to Mexico for
a month and he just left for a month and
might we still paid him and I was like
yeah I was like what the [ __ ] Liam did
my gardener brings me cigars and Bill
thinks it's the best thing is like isn't
a [ __ ] great that you started as a
stand-up comic no hopes of making money
money and now you have a story about
your gardener bringing a cigar yeah like
[ __ ] I get blown away sometimes like
well I took the girls to London I'm sure
I've told this somewhere but I do go to
London and we we had like a driver
taking us out to the UM to this work
Warwick Castle we're gonna spend the
night and we stopped in shakespeare's
hometown to go have lunch on this
butanes river it's just a beautiful
[ __ ] rustic like bread and breakfast
that we're going to night yeah and it's
real rich people [ __ ] and I'd like I
mean we're doing it but it is what rich
people do and then all of a sudden
Leanne just goes I'm getting out of corn
she goes wait wait wait stop and take a
second to be very proud of yourself
because you guys just your silly jokes
got us here like your jokes you just me
going up on an open mic and saying I
think I can do this and then you then
you have the ability to afford to take
your family to Europe
you're like shut the [ __ ] up from
stand-up comedy and it really also to
people listening and I've said this on
other shows what I'm going to say it
again if you haven't heard me talk about
this
find what it is that you really really
love chances are you're listening to
this on a way to a job that you can't
stand but what we have in common and
something magical does happen when you
find the thing that you truly should do
and you love doing and you start doing
it all things fall into place and now
we're sitting in this super [ __ ] cool
man cave and you're able to take your
kids to [ __ ] Europe because go
because I I love it I love stand-up I
love it and I obsess about it I love
watching good stand-up I love like I
just started reading again because I was
like I bet it'll add to my standup yeah
I bet if I have knowledge of [ __ ] I
don't know sure it'll slide away and
slide in the same way it does with I can
tell it's Helen big J Turner sent us
they have some sometimes there's
obscurus references but you they're
funny because you go like where did you
where did you pick that up what did you
do last week like they're almost like
willing to bring in new stuff somebody
in this book about this permit because
I'm part of me wants to just [ __ ]
disappear so I was like maybe I'll maybe
I had a joke but I have to disappear
thing going in a major way so I'm
looking at real estate constantly
thinking about is I'm close now two kids
me and out on the house I'm on the back
end of this thing okay let's start this
very slowly this is I'm having panic
about this so I look at RVs you know
what all right so I want to start we got
to do this this will be our baby steps
and you if me and you do it and I know
we can get Rory Scovel and Jay Larson
and a bunch of other guys with your
heads to do it I want to do a caravan
comedy tour and I want to all of us to
get our own RV your family comes yeah we
set out we pick them up in Phoenix we do
Grand Canyon whatever we do all that
[ __ ] oh and then we go through we do a
show in Tucson and we all camp yeah and
the guys go out at night and do our
shows and all the women and the kids
they [ __ ] camp fire it up and do some
more artists all this stuff let's do
this is summer yeah please I'll be
[ __ ] great we could do it in August
for sure we take them
Bisby to visit uncle Doug I love it have
Doug yeah and I almost bought an RV the
other day really
Leon's obsessed with RVs I'll go with
you to look at him anytime oh because I
bought a 1988 FJ 62 Land Cruiser know
that I know I over and I got it for this
reason to tow a trailer so look at
trailers consoling we look at trailers
non [ __ ] stops you know what a website
I'm on and everybody's got to go to this
website is sports mobile comm and what
they do is they'll take a Dodge Sprinter
and they completely [ __ ] trick it out
now you need about $80,000 but this
thing is loaded and built any way you
want it to be built also you do with a
diesel engine created a website sports
mobile comm now they've been around
forever and it's like a lot of they'll
trick out an Econoline van I'm sure
Brogan has one or closer to my camper
vans yep start looking at some of the
models because then it'll take a diesel
Mercedes huge like sort of touring van
and these are [ __ ] awesome he has two
can I tell you one of my favorite things
to do um I think it's called van life
it's all these rock climbers live out of
their vans and I got one of those dudes
yeah new 70 I did a Sierra Club benefit
with that that like one of the main guys
yeah and then and so they do these tours
of their vans the guy that was on Alex
Alex and Alana hold on a holler I saw he
was the phrasal guy that free-climbed
[ __ ] okay
yeah Capitan yeah I did it a sweetie and
game with him but he was a keynote
speaker and I watched his van life and
they were just taking a tour of his van
and I was like oh this is [ __ ] badass
and I was like oh I want a van and then
I was like oh I'm gonna get a [ __ ]
van what I'm gonna do is get this what
the N and everything it'll get a RV that
we find that and then gut it and make
personalize it and make it ours but yeah
I'm having real sincere panic attacks
oh sit up front Leanne and I said
something I said shouldn't survive well
just - yeah because I
that's how we started this started with
panic attack I wake up in the middle of
the night I said to Lee and I said I
said I want to get a new house I said I
feel like I'm at the age cuz you just
fixed this we just fixed it but now Lee
Anne she goes no this is where I'm gonna
design it is how someone living forever
and then I was like hold on I want one
more I want one more I want a big house
when I go in a house yet I move to that
house yeah we had we remember when me
and my wife came in here like holy [ __ ]
this is our exact same house yeah
because this is all the same stuff it
must've been the same builder we had
every single same everything yeah and we
fixed our place up and then you wait for
the market to get to the perfect place
and you cash out and you guys should
move to the second big one because life
for the one door big one I said I want a
big one with us I want I want to go in
over my head I wanna [ __ ] I want to
really get like a [ __ ] nice house and
it lands like another house and then she
said this I mean the front yard she goes
we gotta figure in six years the girls
gonna be gone it's just gonna be me and
you and I [ __ ] had panic fear through
my heart I was like woo just me and you
I think there's gonna be no distractions
no rodeo clowns in the house like making
noise just me in yes yes yeah we had
both girls leave the house to go to
sleepovers and have it just be you and
Lee Ann in the house no we just had it
me and my wife went out for a hike the
next day we took the dogs on a hike and
we were like look at each other like
what the [ __ ] is this about like oh he
couldn't like us no one because my kids
will bicker you know just our kids bill
and click just there's no problems at
all my kids are great
we'll hang out we're remodeling our
kitchen right now and I love your
kitchen yeah yeah everybody loves my
kitchen it's guess who didn't love it so
I can we're all eatin king taco and sit
there and Oh which leads me to another
story that's just happened last night
so I'd tell my wife I said a lady but I
parked my car right out in front of King
Taco King tacos in LA taco franchise
it's [ __ ] great so I parked the car
Pasadena meters are crazy but I get the
best parking spot look at my wife's car
no quarter tray like I have not a dime
nothing yeah it's all in her purse so I
go into the king taco with my money out
I got $20 and I go hey everybody in line
I just need a quarter I go I'll pay him
right back but if you got two quarters
turn around cheeks is out here I got a
quarter and it is a really super cute in
the face huge boobs Latina chick who
takes out some quarters and gives it to
me
yeah and I'm like oh thank you oh my god
what sort of a meet-cute type of
situation yeah so I'll be right back and
I go and put the quarters and I come
back and then I always do like rewarding
people that are just super nice you know
and I go you know what what are you
getting what are you ordering right now
because I'm just gonna get two tacos to
go now like I'm gonna get you two tacos
yeah so I get a separate receipt and she
was like oh getting my two tacos and at
the end she goes well I'm a hugger can I
give you a hug I was like oh I'm about
that funny to love ya I love getting
hugs so I wasn't get and her friends are
cracking up but you know here she
doesn't have any wedding ring or
anything like that I'm like getting on
now huggin a chicken eating tacos he's
humongous boobs and sick [ __ ] Jesus like
this definitely was a thing but again no
chant-like like I got to go home to you
know my kids are a remodeled kitchen but
as a stand-up comic you know and you
talk about your wife and kids on stage
but there still is like oh six out there
that's the other thing it's like we live
vicariously
through the single comedians you think
about life choices you also think about
like we're closing in on the tail end of
this when it's just going to be you and
your wife in a hammock reading books
you're gonna have reading glass I got
reader I got my readers back there my
wife just bought me oh they're right
here I get my wife bought me uh bought
me nine pairs of readers and then just
put them all over the house because I'm
always like where the [ __ ] of the reach
you've bought nine pairs Amazon you got
Miami Amazon for like three dollars you
get five pairs of glass so anyway we're
closing in on old age and now we're
thinking and I'm looking at houses in
Ojai and I'm looking at both love it a
lot yeah I want to be able to like go
there come down work in LA and go back
and just herm it out so that's what I
feel like we're on the same page with
that you know what's so funny I maybe I
just maybe I need to buy a house in like
Big Bear or oh hi angelic Arrowhead when
we're off the podcast yeah I'm going to
go on give a real estate ads I have red
fin Trulia Zillow
alright Zillow Trulia none red fin check
those out about right now so I go on
there and I look at Lake Arrowhead and I
look at all these other little places
you can somebody was telling me about
pioneer town everyone's moving to
pioneer town really here's what I want
to do this is what exactly want to do I
want to [ __ ] in my kids to go off to
college and then I want to do a tour
with other dads whose kids are off in
college and their wives and like we all
just go like me you who else's got kids
are off a Tom Pappas on top yeah we all
bring our wives and our and it's just
like we get like a like a tour bus and
or RV and we all are in the just the
dads the wives and we're doing like dad
and wife [ __ ] like going out to eat at
night to nice places going wine tastes
and we do the show and everything pays
for it yeah oh [ __ ]
so that's this you just described the or
go camping I just pitched my idea
very good to the I'm not [ __ ] on
Barry Barry's got a new movie coming out
here might be my own podcast
Barry cats wouldn't suck there's a new
movie coming out about himself
no but documentary he did
[ __ ] meant to reply to him I'm sorry
can someone tell Barry I watched it I
liked it
and I want to talk to him about it um I
shouldn't talk about it til I get some
thing but he one time we were in a
meeting and I I pitched an idea and I
pitched the idea was a guy goes out on
three dates with three different women
I'm the host except you don't know the
girls don't know that I'm the host so
like if he takes him out to eat on the
waiter if they go to surf instructor
surf lessons on the surf instructor if
they go rock climbing I'm the rock
climbing instructor and my goal is just
to make sure he isn't set up in the best
scenario every time I'm his wingman and
then Barry any clear wingman yeah and so
Barry Louie and it was me and Louie
Anderson Louie Anderson was producing it
Barry Barry we were producing it I was
hosting it and then I pitched it and
Barry goes I got a better idea
hong-won if you don't they don't know
that you're the host and you are like
the wingman and look at me because did
he just pitch your idea to here I think
so
I'm very good I like it okay here we go
I like it and so we did it and it and
then Louie fired Barry and they never
tried to sell it it's a good idea
there's so many of those ideas the
comedians have and they again um that'd
be a show that we could make so we're
getting enough money at all things
comedy yeah to produce shows we were
talking about producing specials we're
gonna we're going to do all of that now
also have full transparency I did my
show my special with a production
company I don't know how much was spent
on Acts and you know it's like I know
that it costs a lot of money yeah but I
know that Jay Larson just did his for 40
grand
I know Felipe shot his own what we'll do
whatever shoot just sizzles know the
entire special oh they shot their
special they shot their entire special
cost but I but I know how much mine
cause I know mr. Gore's cost and like
because they shot him themselves no no
that was the budget that I put
and company you the budget I know what
the but we all know what the budgets are
yeah I want to know what it really call
it of really cause that's what I'm
getting right so what I did I called
high noon my production company and what
that was doing trip flip when I want to
do a special I had an outstanding offer
at Showtime Gary Garfinkel had said
whenever you want to shoot your special
Gary Graham fringle did the coolest
Hollywood thing you know Gary now I
think he's still at Showtime I'm almost
certain yes he's in character the
acquisitions busy I think so um yeah so
I'm in Montreal this is my favorite this
is one of the like solid [ __ ]
Hollywood stories I'm in Montreal two
years ago three years ago
maybe three years ago I don't know and
I'm doing my hour for all the buyers HBO
Netflix how many cents for how many
central they're all at the nest I think
I was in the nest and they're all
watching me run that do my hour to see
if they want to buy it I'm nervous [ __ ]
gonna [ __ ] like I don't and Gary
Garfinkel comes up to my green room with
two Jameson's hands me one and he goes
have a great show I said thanks just you
know I'll buy it
I don't what he goes I buy it you don't
even need to do the hour I buy it I was
like really goes yes so there's no
pressure it's already been sold so go
and have a great show and I was like I
was like [ __ ] thank you dude that was
the coolest thing
what a sweet [ __ ] wood it just you
don't hear about those great stories and
good people like this great it [ __ ]
guy and I was like dude I was like you
have no idea how big how monumental that
is to me because now I get to have a
great now I get to go out knowing that I
get a seven point lead you know and I
you know I just got a not fumble the
ball it's all well show time put out
some really shitty comedy and has been
associated with some really bad stand-up
but thanks to Sebastian yo thanks to
yourself and I feel they're doing one
with Eric Griffin and Santina because
the I'm dying up here thing I'd only
like I'm in really good company going
into this like I say I say I quit
yeah and success not an idle threat like
like
and people are like listening probably
going in I can quit I'm gonna walk I
came back for you but I it's good you
know like said my other one was on
Comedy Central and Comedy Central airs
this [ __ ] Oh on Friday night at midnight
and then doesn't have any streaming
option for you to watch it they think
they do but not want anyone even knows
about or is aware of I had they don't
put any money behind like hey Comedy
Central streaming you can watch all of
these specials
there's no billboard that's ever existed
for that there's no marketing campaigns
like you and all these comedians have in
common they did a Comedy Central special
and you can watch them all here for five
bucks a month they don't have any
outreach like that so there's a ton of
us that have done
Comedy Central specials which again my
other one why is the rabbit crying
showed up on every single top-10 list
for the year no one sighs yeah no one
saw mine
no one and if they did joining that yeah
that's that's it you know the real irony
that I'm gonna desire knee but the real
[ __ ] hilariousness of this we all
shot specials for Comedy Central at the
same time me Chris Titus Dober and Pete
corioli okay we all got the exact same
note we're dark colored jeans with a
dark colored shirt with a sit with a
poodle with with a with a Nowak Witten
and we all wore black shirts with dark
jeans all of us we look identical
hilarious not you couldn't tell any of
our specials apart and and they were all
shot in the exact same theater so we're
wearing the same outfit what is [ __ ]
the only difference is I have some
facial hair yeah but it was like [ __ ]
clothes we got until bill takes his
business to Netflix and then and other
people start doing Netflix specials
that's why I what's the next one going
to be what's the next thing going to be
because it can't like that right
sometimes it's a good spot you know what
ideally then that next thing is going to
be is well you know call things comedy
is can start doing specials and then
sell them to these other places and
we're going
do exactly what you know I'm shooting my
next one in
I haven't I guess I'm announcing this
now but I'm shooting my next one in
February and yeah at the Trocadero
that's a great spot to shoot and I'm my
grandmother's gonna be 98
yeah and I was going I'm gonna ever
bring me on stage that's awesome yeah so
but yeah I've already as a mid I got to
figure out a couple more stories but I'm
doing the roads so aggressively and you
know then yeah and I'm not doing theater
I'm doing theatres in Australia but I'm
not doing the oh by the way I'm doing on
splat tour in Australia everybody that's
awesome and and so but I'm doing clubs
because I want to keep doing I want to
get it in wrote like I admit I missed
that when I was young when I was hungry
and I was like [ __ ] on the road that
was to a weekend and you'd [ __ ]
really just it's almost like you when
you do a lot an act yeah you you perfect
it and you almost have like all the
instead of like you're a butcher and
you've got every night for your disposal
when you're just when you're doing
television you just don't stand up every
now and then it's like you go I got one
knife I know I are one night picking cut
let's just hope but right now I'm like
I'm [ __ ] I did like 18 weeks in a row
and I [ __ ] came out like with huge
chunks worked out I was like that this
one [ __ ] talked about yeah see I don't
yeah I have the opposite of that I have
no I have this special and then I have
no and a couple things drop in my lap
and she's like oh that could be a bit
that could be a bit yeah but now I'm
like all my efforts are concentrated on
like writing and this movie and
producing the show but that's I don't I
think you'd be bored just to extend up
you're different than all of us I've
always said this Tom and I've always
said this you're different than all of
us because you can do what we all do but
you can also do a hundred other things
so that's i sat with this guy Jonathan
Groff who is one of the executive
producers of blackish and he was the
showrunner for happy endings at the time
I was telling them about my background
and I didn't even think twice about it
but now it's sort of coming back to me
he goes oh dude he goes you're gonna be
a great show runner you be sure what all
you be a fantastic and that's what's
happening and I had this deal with CBS
and I go I would like to match up with
one of your Latino show runners if
possible and he goes there are no Latino
show runners I go really and he goes
that's what you are man and then got a
phone call where somebody wants me to be
that and then I have this Comedy Central
thing where I'm the creative and creator
and executive producer and I am the
showrunner
yeah that's starting to happen and then
also you get to stay I get a little huge
amount of like satisfaction from writing
jokes for other people you have them
kill me and Kevin Christie watch Tim
Allen come out of retirement the other
in the Laugh Factory and he was working
[ __ ] out so this is a guy who used to be
on the top of the top of the world
there's all the C in the class movies
home-improvement hugely successful goes
on stage at the Laugh Factory and people
were thrilled to see him but it wasn't
good yeah and he hadn't worked it out so
I walked up to his assistant and I
talked to Tim and I go hey do you mind
we just watch that I want to come
tomorrow night I'm going to record and
then I'm going to go back and I go just
so we can do it and I handed that [ __ ]
nine pages of jokes yeah and I saw me
and Kevin Chris high-fived because he
got a standing ovation Chris bucket set
and he got a huge applause break after
one of our bits and we were like boom
I couldn't walked away and he never like
there was no compensation yeah
there was zero I didn't expect it didn't
ask for it didn't even think about it
and if I can handle a guy nine pages and
some more great but it worked in with
his all the premises that he had yeah I
took him and we just wrote a wall out
and just Rick had bits for him and then
he killed Hickock I was so excited
watching another dude I can kill with my
material like oh this is great yeah so I
get a credit not a new
I didn't like it so much when I watched
other dudes killed my metier ago well
when you hand them the sheet of paper
yeah yeah I would love my problem is I
am so I'm so I have a really hard time
taking advice from anyone else like I
see I don't it's I like someone someone
just it was like I'm a ratash one time I
was like hey man you should I like that
black chick
he always wanted a black chick joke he
should keep that but I have a joke that
I can't use that you should use to open
it like I did joke about always wanted
dated black chick and then I went to
this scenario what it would be like like
go to her house or brothers working on
the front yard working on the front yard
with a Glocks Glocks and attacks and
there are others in the pit bulls one
dudes in a wheelchair with a pacifier
and then you're like hey fellas licorice
here and and but Tosh is like you need
to open it with I've always wanted to
date a black chick just as long as
you've never had sex with a black guy
and I was like it's not a great joke but
I could never do it
I could never why because it was his
because he gave it to me and I was like
and I was like yeah I don't know if I
don't write it I don't want to do it
like yeah like I'm it's part of part of
the thing is like when I do stand-up
you're this is I'm showing you what I
can do
that's me this is everything is Bert
Kreischer Bert Kreischer did all this if
it's hacky it's because Burke rice was a
little hacking yeah yeah it'll I'll
never steal I'll never borrow I'll never
if I find a theme is treading on someone
else's theme I [ __ ] bail on it oh
this special [ __ ] I have a thing and
I don't really watch many stand-ups yeah
and he came up to me afterwards and
we're really good friends that's why
psych I'm buddies with this guy I like
him a lot he's running for Sebastian oh
yeah
so Sebastian comes to me and I have this
in my special maybe 12 minutes of this
Yelp thing where I went to a restaurant
I found this review afterwards like I
talked about how my wife is obsessed
with it but then I was going through and
I was watching some of the ocean I was
going on Showtime seeing how mine would
be listed yeah and then I had never seen
any Sebastian specials before so I was
like I'll just click on
this a little nugget of exactly my Yelp
thing really and he comes up to me
accuracy and this is me doing a set like
seven months ago and he goes
they Yelp things hilarious how long you
been doing that and I know and I go oh
Jesus I've been carrying around this
[ __ ] material for four years like the
worst
I don't do Alec I waited and long it's a
way to look like that and then he goes
okay and I wasn't you know we're again
we're friendly and I thought he was just
admired a bit because a couple of people
came up like I perfected it once I
started working on it yeah and again
it's 12 minutes it's not like I take the
same nugget of a premise that the body
was thought of well it's just Yelp like
not once have I ever thought to [ __ ]
log in after having a club sandwich like
I don't understand any of the mentality
of anybody who's reviewing anything I
really don't if you're not a
professional [ __ ] you reviewer
getting paid for it
I don't understand who's [ __ ] taking
the time out of their lives doing is a
me shut the [ __ ] up where to god you
ready I'll read you one of my reviews
for what do I got five you have so much
[ __ ] going on such a waste of time
unless you use all has a bit [ __ ]
noise swear to God so what I would do I
my reviews aren't on here among the eyes
on a different account um probably
restaurants a hundred percent so we both
this is both of our joke and I did this
I do this all the time they tell you can
i tell you that i believe i when i watch
i watch the Sebastien's the first one i
think the one that really popped for him
i watched it just sit in the mancave one
night it came on and i'm having a glass
of wine and i'm like oh this shit's
[ __ ] funny i don't and i don't think
we allow you just loved him yeah we in
the back of the comedy store me monsieur
brogni and Steve Rannazzisi and remember
I was just hanging out with boss the
other day he's great I was on my good
good friends so we would drink and we
would be this is like 2005 2004 and we'd
watch Sebastian and [ __ ] be hunched
over laughing and again this is a comedy
store there's 12 people in the audience
we're drunk and it's late and it's like
dude he would
always killed me I think he's talking
one of the best standards ever been like
he just I love it all which by the way I
keep meaning to give him [ __ ] when I see
him because he had a baby bash do you
know about this though because he does
this whole thing aren't you embarrassed
yes he had a baby bash where all the
guys dressed up is in onesies and they
had like a baby party where they all
dressed his babies and I was like what
the [ __ ] is this this is where the first
thing that was like holy [ __ ] like
aren't you [ __ ] embarrassed like dude
are you so theory I watch The Bachelor
special and I said he when he goes who
are these people
I I sat in my man cave and I go me I
everything that drives him nuts about
people I do all the time like I do
hoodies people to take their shirt off
at a game I'm like me definitely me like
um
so I write I write yelp reviews but
they're extensive so like yeah that's
one thing I can't understand people
wasting their time I just don't get a
job I'm not following
no no I just I do it for fun for me so I
do it I would get BLTs everywhere when I
was on the road for Travel Channel I get
BLTs everywhere I go and I'd review the
B LTS a very simple sandwich but I would
leave like a [ __ ] three paragraph
review on there BLT too much mayonnaise
like oh the the bacon feels like it was
sourced at it from a New Zealand farm
just outside Queensland that's how good
this bit like I would just on Iran and I
would have so much fun but I can't find
him on my [ __ ] thing it must be on a
different account but yeah I used to
write Revell I haven't written a yelp
review in a long time well it's the same
bit that we had was like why don't you
just walk up to the manager and go hey
this place [ __ ] - you're dis
restaurant he's disgusting I walked out
I was at a Buffalo Wild Wings with my
family son said that's where you want to
go on his birthday there's two years ago
my little Buffalo Wild Wings just the
worst service worst experience gross
people next to us and I got some snob we
were just like I've been to plenty of
Buffalo Wow
I'm not about but this one was a bad one
we went to one we went to in Pasadena on
I believe it's on Raymond was a bad is a
bad [ __ ] Wild Wings a reviewer
Buffalo Wild Wings one time Kate and I
look I walked up to the manager and I go
hey this place is a [ __ ] mess like a
waitress is slow and she's an [ __ ]
yeah I go this is [ __ ] everything about
this place sucks
yeah and you're over here chit-chatting
yo just so you know I will know she
walked away and again that's the whole
thing it's like ten seconds there's my
review right here [ __ ] face well I
did a long time ago I was in Baltimore
and I was right I was staying downtown
and I walked to this restaurant forget
the name in the place I go to the
restaurant Millie afternoon I get a beer
and and I have an order sandwich I asked
him I said what's the best thing you got
and he says I don't know man
and I go okay I said is anything good he
goes I don't know man look at the menu
so I'm like [ __ ] I looking here so I
look at the menu and I say I think I'm
trying to be healthy I say I said how's
the turkey thing is good it was so bad
that I wrote a rough yelp review I was
like personally I would never attend
this place ever the the bartender was a
dick the sandwich was horrible and I put
it on Yelp and then I said as i was
doing Rogan and I said yeah I I've given
a bad rope yelp review I gave it on this
place in Baltimore and the [ __ ] dude
contacted me the manager contacted me
that's the other thing is if you put a
bad reviews they [ __ ] they they kind
of like reply and they reply it reached
out to me he [ __ ] emailed me what'd
he say he was like he was like hey man
so you headed I'm sorry had a bad thing
but you can't do that to my business
you're destroying my business you just
won on the biggest podcast in the world
and talk [ __ ] about my place we got
people in Baltimore listen to Rogan are
coming down to my [ __ ] restaurant
telling me that we were dicks to the
Machine and he was like and now I'm
looking at everyone's replying to your
yelp review I mean could you please take
it down and I was like come on your
[ __ ] service was bad this is how it
works and then I was like [ __ ] I go I
don't want this energy I'm sorry I took
it down and I was like I go I'm sorry
bro but like yeah I don't want to shut
down a business you don't
also realize like you know if your
that's what because brings us also back
to [ __ ] if that waiter bartender was
a miserable man yeah that's not what
they should be doing
Oh our waitress in Calgary I'll and and
Scott picks me up and go to his
restaurant to go eat dinner cuz it's
like late our waitress hits it we sit
down she goes uh-huh do you guys is
really going to sit and have dinner now
I'm like excuse me she's like I was just
about to be get cut and now I gotta wait
on you guys blown away hey do you notice
about Calgary I was there with Tosh yeah
I've never seen more single lonely men
walking around by themselves in my
entire life well I but at my show there
are a lot of us I was looking at is like
what the [ __ ] is this people these guys
just walking around and their home was
either yeah looks just a shopping bag I
wanted to do a video because I was down
by the by the Prince Island I think and
ever was jogging and I was like I think
Canadians jog different than Americans
because my theory is there's a comic
Robert Patrice who's a boxer who I was a
friend of mine and we and one day he
said to me do you think cavemen jogged
the way we jog or do you think they ran
differently I said what do you mean he
goes well our jog is based on watching
black people run like his boss on
basketball like you see him jog down the
court so we jog cooler he got cooler and
I was like I was thinking about there I
wouldn't tell us the jokes with kind of
Roberts joke but they'd like Jazzercise
a java weird Canadians John a little
different than us and I think it's cuz
they don't have a ton of black people
yeah like and because our run is based
off of our sports we watch our sports
that's how I learned where I run as a
kid I watched I watched [ __ ] do you
run why you look like - I know how to
run yeah I run like I look like I know
how to run Yeah right that's exactly
what it is and that's you tribute that
to watching a lot of purple black guys
play sports
yeah I'm sure yeah that's a good runner
yeah there I know how
looks yeah hey you know what's hat Ricky
Bell sure Ricky Bell I used to watch him
run and I thought who is your NFL team
books it was for a long time nobody else
which two Rams huh yeah we'll get these
Rams games and she were in this jazz
hand the oldest guys how clever be good
so like when I go you're just wearing a
you need you'll go off flex fit is the
brand oh no no no no they do it or did a
large resonator no no no you've no idea
how big my head is just put it on for so
what size is put it on just put it on
just watch you're slow forget a little
boy Panther boy I what happens is fans
will know that I'm coming to a place
fitted eight yeah well I'm seven and
three eighths I'm eight like a legit
eight and so I fail here company shows
none apparel company shows with their
minor league baseball team as a size
eight I love it's my favorite thing ever
this dude did it in San Diego we brought
me an old-school Padres hat it's one of
my favorite hats ever I wear it all the
[ __ ] time
got it yeah I'm a crazy person that
won't go to Seattle because that's how
much I hate the Seahawks I got an
audition for a movie later this
afternoon and I'm not thinking about
going because the character rocks a
Seahawks Jersey really [ __ ] the Seahawks
[ __ ] all you Seahawks fans with your
[ __ ] face paint you'll look like Kurt
Warner's wife is [ __ ] you just add
face paint 12th man [ __ ] that you stole
from Texas A&M but it should be ashamed
of yourselves
[ __ ] seriously Pete Carroll and his
plastic surgery pieces [ __ ] [ __ ] god
they're also a marker for stand up yeah
[ __ ] not going back ever and now
again I know I'm not missed yeah look at
what you do
oh yeah I just hate it I hate you I'm so
passionate about hatred for teams that I
went to a Dallas Cowboys game at the 49
49ers or [ __ ] right now we're all
looking like we have a chance because of
Kyle Shanahan John Lynch and we're
definitely me and soda and like a bunch
of these guys were very
about the prospect of us getting better
because we're a horrible horrible team
that is on the rebound we've got great
days whatever but I went to a Dallas
Cowboys game and I told my buddy who
works in management there is one of the
worst sports experiences I've ever had
in my entire life why as I went and I
was in the parking lot
my son was throwing a football with his
cousin and some fat [ __ ] overweight
Mexican guy in a you know good Earvin
jersey eighty eight o'clock and he autos
up mr. [ __ ] kid broke like that and
like kids the car is hitting the ball
was like you know the bad pass it would
roll into somebody's bumper and it was
you're playing catch with a football in
a football stadium parking lot yeah
isn't not new yeah right it's what's
done and you can tell your [ __ ] kid
bro [ __ ] it I like that and my son and
my little little nephew were there and I
was so pissed and as I walked back and I
go kids you stay here and I go I need
every guy at this tailgate to come with
me right now every single one of them
yeah so 15 dudes walk back to the guy
and I go okay look how this convert the
kids aren't around let's talk about this
again you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I get
real brave when there's a lot of other
guys you can kiss my ass you know one of
my buddies uh who's a guy Tito Ortiz
yeah yeah well this kid that we hang was
there as a wrestler wrestled him kicked
his ass in high school like there yeah
really yeah because Joey Oliveira was
just [ __ ] badass in high schooler's of
badass high school wrestler that's why I
could never be around MMA guys cuz I
would always be [ __ ] bravest you know
Joe bartnick yeah so that's my first
comedy fights I was uh hanging out
backstage and me and Joe I picked him up
world my kurz we are in San Francisco
well that's probably use from up there
yeah so Joel bartnik is standing
in the back we're going to go do
something afterwards and I'm in my
takeoff a tie I will go to work every
day I take off tie go sit backstage and
I'm with this black guy from Oakland
named hatch and another come here hatch
his catchphrases my shit's funny and so
me and hatch are backstage were buddies
and he goes up and does a set and then
he comes back
it's just a curtain in the stage yeah
and then this guy who's like a spoken
word dude from Benicia goes up and he
starts we were just talking to each
other being actually over here [ __ ]
hatch and something about hatches mom
he's incorporating it into his like
comedy poetry [ __ ] and then he says
something else I go he must knows and I
have a beer I'm drinking in a class and
I go [ __ ] this I go let's go kick this
guy's ass
so he's on stage doing the set yeah I
pop out behind a curtain and I take the
microphone out of his hand I go [ __ ]
throw it down I go show's over
[ __ ] and we look and I grab him
I push him up against the wall all his
friends go up hatch comes up slaps the
[ __ ] beer out of his hand oh we got
this guy up against the wall and I go I
don't know what the [ __ ] you were doing
up there like happy you never come back
to [ __ ] the city and think you can do
[ __ ] stand up here again
oh my god yeah and I go get the [ __ ] out
of here like that and I was so brave
because Joel Bartnik six-foot-five
[ __ ] standing at the side of the room
catchers Miss Ferrara I know anything
really goes down yeah but you know I'm
so [ __ ] crazy I really feel like if
there was a fight that I would be fine
you know against they're not fighting a
professional but you know I did it
that's my big fear is that you start a
fight and then like I had Nicky Gaul in
here you know Mickey Hall he's the guy
who beat CM Punk he had him in here he
comes over and he was he was talking I
haven't really spot cast yet I'll really
sit and I think next week I gotta find
it but he was saying he got into a bar
fight
and he was like
like there's a moment oh no there's a
moment where he gets on top of the guy
and the guy tries to do something Nick
he's like I know it he's like keeps it
he's a pro fighter so he's like oh this
guy's [ __ ] Ville and he's like just
like the guy tries to pull guard or do
something and the best one ever is
Michiel either one the best one ever is
giving him story about Rogaine tape
mm-hmm
is one of my favorite [ __ ] stories I
don't know why I enjoyed so much I loved
hate luck tastes to him stand up now
really yep that's a good guy like that
talking dog take my keys again
he came to the all things comedy open
house yeah yeah it was there he's cheap
so they go Kate and Joe or have a
connecting rooms there to you know walk
through the door yeah
so go down at the bar and there's just
[ __ ] walking around with his shirt
off in Vegas and he's just [ __ ] start
he's going as people and picking fights
like trying to pick a fight and that
allowed like glass and security I'm like
so
Kate and Joe see this tonight whatever
[ __ ] that guy [ __ ] they're like world
only a part of this they get out there
there they go up to the room when we get
up to Joe's room the guys trying to get
into Joe's room he's trying to use his
key to get in his room Joe says hey man
that's my room and I was like no it's
not and he goes yeah it is
take goes to his room and opens his door
like waits for Joe but opens his door
neither's no it is my room he goes no
stop [ __ ] you and then Joe takes his key
and he opens the door he goes see this
is my room and the guys like and Joyce
and the guys don't [ __ ] walk away
from me [ __ ] and he's like Joe just
shuts his door and then he starts
banging on [ __ ] Joe's door cake comes
into Joe's room and Joe's like what are
we gonna do it tastes like let's [ __ ]
this guy up so he take goes outside by
the way I'm [ __ ] the story updated if
it's different I apologize
Kate goes out of his room and goes hey
buddy
and the guy takes a swing at tape takes
a pro fighter so he's like oh I got this
at this moment Security's coming up with
his with his friends the security guards
are coming up the elevator with his
friends coming up the elevator Joe goes
out his door they [ __ ] go at it they
end on the grant they land on the ground
they puts them in a omoplata like a
[ __ ] move and the security guard goes
guys break it up in Joe goes give them
one
second he's a professional mixed martial
artist he's just gonna put the guy to
sleep and the guy goes what [ __ ]
jokes about sleep anyone friends are
like watch wisely like he's calling the
bite don't worry he's a professional
mesmerized
he's just gonna put him to sleep I'm the
guys like oh oh it's my favor I love
that story that's awesome yeah you don't
know your if I had also like I don't I
again it's like this like where I see
gross injustice like I see somebody like
I see somebody hitting a woman or
something like that I'm coming in like I
don't care for who the [ __ ] they are I'm
flying in the guy just I can't help it I
just it's always what I've always done
like I will see anything I saw again had
seen some crazy [ __ ] like I'll go flying
I saw a big [ __ ] fight in a safe way
so homeless and in San Francisco doing
the punchline and this black guy walks
in he's got a backpack I sort of see a
machete there's a couple security or
standing around I'm gonna get some [ __ ]
from my hotel room and I'm walking
around and I see the Skyler trying to
squirt this guy out he's got a back page
of shoplifting you're trying to shoplift
and the guy turns around whips off
full-on fight where the guy picks the
homeless guy up pulls them onto the big
display of strawberries they're in the
middle of all the berries you know and
that big guy Linden yeah yeah yeah yeah
so in the produce section it's just
[ __ ] full on strawberry fight like we
were there into the flowers you know how
they oh the whole flower section near
the hose go flying into that and then I
go and I see this and know everyone's
just standing around couple people pick
up their phones and start filming yeah
as I [ __ ] this and I go up to the light
and I gain the deepest now I'm loud
I get really loud yeah and I go I go
it's over
stop yeah stop now stop now and they
both just look up at me mid brawl
and stop yeah and [ __ ] like and I was
on top of them and like really
authoritative [ __ ] and then you know did
fully stopped it was crazy it was just I
told two people to stop fighting yeah
yes [ __ ] I wish I could put a guy to
sleep and then um this guy was heinous
[ __ ] I was [ __ ] crazy you al Madrigal
I am I am Al matter I I can't help but
get involved when I see something if I
could and then I give there's [ __ ] going
I will mix it up like yeah I have I do
have a thing where I can't come back
from it like if I I've been feeling
helpless lately so when I see
helplessness happen I can't stop it I
can't [ __ ] stop it like I when I see
someone taking advantage of someone I
[ __ ] it [ __ ] it makes me insane Oh
something exactly the all my mind well I
can I do something this is we bring us
full again I keep saying this a million
times play where you have so many
different tangents that we're coming
back to and this is a tangent that
brings us back to the special in this
special coach for opinion easy
tell the shrimp revenge story you told
me that you told me that a long time ago
rising right what had happened I told
John Hodgman from The Daily Show and he
goes are you doing that as a bit and I
go no because I really did it I don't
want to be liable he goes comedian sued
for shrimping is the best article
headline and press you could ever have
hoped that the lady comes after you um
hopefully you watch a special and it
goes into what the seafood revenge sort
of story is but I flipped out at my
daughter's day in studio and this is
what I did and that's what the special
is called and so I'm hoping people watch
it's May 5th it goes on Showtime and
then it's streaming like you said and
then I'll get a Vietnamese guy yeah
listen we've done like two hours we
should play well yes up the it's on
Saturday night Friday night Friday night
May 5th a camp at nah yeah I think 9
p.m. their job or yeah and people and
also there's a code did they give you a
code for a free half-hour show time with
yours yes
oh you know what they know you know what
they did you can download that you can
download the Showtime app and get a free
trial dude you guys got to do this yeah
if you haven't done it for bird special
now you get to do it you need to watch
my special birds but if they give you a
free Showtime I think they're giving me
a code I haven't I get it this week and
yeah that's uh that's it Oh what are you
doing are you on the road this weekend
May 5th and 6th okay what were you doing
I just got I'm doing the ice house with
rent as easy as wondering if you wanted
to join no I'm at the Cincinnati funny
bone how cool
yeah the fifth and so the Liberty
Township funny bone and then uh and then
that's it all right well I'm dying up
here and I hope people watch a special
and it's no threat with all this stuff
like again nobody cares but I hope you
enjoy this special that's what is it's a
special [ __ ] event clubs nobody fun ones
are all things comedy website gonna be
up promptly we've had to put it off a
little bit but definitely by like late
summer all new website all new like it's
just going to be amazing it should be
the one spot you go to for all things
comedy calendar sections with all of our
comics on tour and just really building
it out and giving you guys access that
nobody else has I want to give you all I
want to give just favorite stuff have a
bunch of those blogs I'll give you all
those blogs users oh yeah yeah I need
all that [ __ ] there yeah I got to tell
you about something else off here that I
can't announce super [ __ ] exciting so
a lot of great stuff happened for a TC
but thanks if you're listening to this
point and you just listen to this to our
podcast you're the reason why we're able
to make all this happen so thank you if
you look at this point right now we
should right now's when we should talk
[ __ ] about comics keep a secret don't
[ __ ] tweet and also don't be a [ __ ]
disturber yeah you hear somebody open up
don't go hey they were drinking
gangbanging medium you hear news that
they arson so-and-so said this about you
don't be a little [ __ ] rat although I
do love when
hey man just give me a heads up someone
talk [ __ ] about you yeah p.m. I'm like
really yam is great yeah don't worry
about the world and dying like yeah yeah
I took a lot of [ __ ] I have a truck of
water
[Music]
you
this episode was brought to you by the
machine
you